the empire
[Music]
[Applause]
they're everywhere
[Music]
but the world here
belongs to syndicates
[Music]
I want to survive
I have to play their game
looks like I'm all in
she's in here somewhere one second
thought I'm out
[Music]
I've been held back my whole life
and now
I just need a chance to finally be free
wherever that takes me
here to offer you a way out okay
get off my ship Jalen
give me a chance
you're gonna have to trust me you'll be
dangerous risky but if you pull this off
you'll never look over your shoulder
again
[Music]
the underworld shows no mercy
but it's a big Galaxy out there and I'm
gonna risk it All
[Music]
Star Wars Outlaws coming 2024
snake flicks its tongue as a leather
boot steps past it up Stone steps a bit
of dark-haired man removes a hood he is
in a columned cavern bless him a secret
ceremony
are you ready to give up who you once
thought you were I am a Ubisoft original
a hand runs along an ornate carpet
beardless the dark head man moves
through a bustling Bazaar
vendor's bargain tea is poured
ready to sacrifice everything you have
clothes
I am a dark head woman stares a merchant
bumps a vendor the dark head man
snatches a coin purse from the vendor's
waist but guards pursue him
ceremony
to leave your life
with shadows I am the dark-haired man
takes a heated blade in ancient Baghdad
he flees the gods through a darkened
tunnel he pulls the market stall down
behind him tripping a guard a guard
swings a sword at the dark-haired man as
he tries to climb a city wall but falls
to the ground the guard backhands him as
others surround him two of the three
guards dropped to the ground with knives
protruding from their backs a hooded
dark-haired assassin swings down from
the scaffolding taking out the remaining
God
then out of the dark you will come into
the light in a darkened Tower he appears
bearded and wearing an Assassin's Hood
as she helps him up he blocks her blade
as she swings at him they block and duck
one another's blows out onto scaffolding
surrounding the unfinished Tower he
pursues her to an edge he smirks then
lunges she twists behind him then pushes
him over the edge
from the line in the ceremony you will
return to the dark she covers Embers he
lowers the heated blade over his left
hand she gazes towards him he grimaces
he clutches his hand
never forget the tenets you have sworn
to uphold standing on a tower he
overlooks sprawling Baghdad soldiers
escort a nobleman past beggars
stay your blade from the Flesh of the
innocent missing a ring finger the dark
head man reaches out hide in place he
impales three Soldiers with a hidden
blade
never compromise the Brotherhood the
nobleman points as his soldiers charge
at the dark-haired man who throws a
smoke bomb the air fills with red smoke
then Fades to reveal the dark head man
as he kills two more men soldiers chase
after him he glances at a hawk flying
overhead then climbs onto a rooftop a
soldier collapses from poisonous gas two
remaining soldiers Rush the nobleman
down an alley to a courtyard
a soldier hurls flaming material from a
fire at the Assassin who Dodges it the
Assassin uses the second Soldier as a
human shield before stabbing the first
from this day forward the no woman tries
to flee you are a hidden one the dark
head man drops down in front of the
nobleman who swings a knife wildly the
nobleman checks his waist as the
Assassin throws a golden mask to the
ground he hurls sand back at the
Assassin who Ducks it the Assassin
twists behind him then puts a blade to
his neck title Assassin's Creed Mirage
in a realm of Shadows the Assassin looks
up from the nobleman raised in gray
smoke a ghoulish creature stares back at
him
coming 2023
[Music]
at launch Ghost Recon breakpoint was
busted and kinda boring it got written
off by a bunch of people and rightly so
but what if I told you in the five years
since release it has become one of the
best Ghost Recon games of all time and
an excellent open world game hello and
welcome to Gamespot no HUD the show
where we take a look at some of your
favorite games and tweak the settings
just enough to create a brand new
experience today we're taking a look at
Ghost Recon breakpoint and we're going
to turn this into the Tactical tense
shooter that we all wanted now this is
going to be a tough Mission so we've
recruited deep Ghost Recon expert to
guide us along the way
foreign
[Music]
built upon 2017's Ghost Recon wildlands
as another open world Ghost Recon game
however instead of refining its Co-op
sandbox and the Tactical opportunities
it presented breakpoint buried those
core ideas under a loot-based shooter
with color-coded loot gear scores and
even raids yes they put raids in a ghost
recon game while the moment-to-moment
gameplay was nearly identical to
wildlands the loot grind not only
compromised the identity of Ghost Recon
but also poisoned the entire experience
for many the pitch was a tactical
shooter with survival mechanics some of
which were interesting others of which
felt underdeveloped the delivery however
was an underwhelming Ghost Recon game
that abandoned ITS Tactical roots in
favor of chasing Trends with a poorly
implemented live service model it was a
disaster from top to bottom but this is
a Redemption story
so how do we turn this mess into one of
the best tactical Shooters on the market
we'll take you through the process to
show you how we'll be incorporating
tweaks and new features that ubisoft's
own patches introduced before taking
matters into our own hands with a mod
that is going to rework The Experience
significantly and will have deep explain
what the impact of this is
thankfully Ubisoft did some of the heavy
lifting back in 2020 when it introduced
something called ghost experience
parameters yes it's really called ghost
experience parameters this update
allowed players to hop in the settings
menu and rebalance the entire game in a
matter of seconds more importantly you
can even turn off the terrible gear
score and loot system altogether which
we're gonna do right now I've got
nothing against loot systems I've played
my fair share of Destiny and they can
offer a rewarding Loop but they don't
belong in a ghost recon game what Elite
operative is constantly changing their
clothes and tossing away equipment for
new ones that incrementally make them
feel more powerful none the answer is
none so where do we go from here well
this is where deep comes in he's put in
over 600 hours in breakpoint and he
doesn't just play this game he makes it
sing
it has to be extreme I have the Tactical
difficulty put up to Elite and the
interface the whole HUD is pretty much
nothing I don't have Anna hang up except
for the objective that I'm going to just
because if I don't have guided mode on I
will go on the tangent and I will get
lost it's pretty much Bare Bones zero
HUD and just a little bit of guidance
from the game well this show is called
no HUD so I guess it makes sense just to
turn basically everything off like Steve
said the only thing I'm going to leave
on are the objective markers so I don't
get lost or distracted however when
watching Deep's gameplay I did notice
one important HUD element missing
reticles yeah no Crosshair which was a
learning experience but I feel like the
more I play it I'm looking for more and
more of a challenge and to be more
immersed and yeah across hair was
breaking the immersion for me a little
bit so I got rid of it this may seem
daunting even a bit absurd for a third
person shooter with over-the-shoulder
aiming but breakpoint provides you with
the tools to overcome this the obvious
choice is to turn off over the shoulder
aiming altogether this means that aiming
will default to iron sights and Scopes
if you prefer the over-the-shoulder
style of aiming you can track down a
laser sight that said if you've never
played breakpoint before I don't
recommend turning everything off right
out of the gate now the gameplay
experience will be predominantly defined
by the Tactical difficulty menu here you
can tweak a wide range of settings that
can fundamentally change the game the
biggest example of this is gear score
which we've already turned off while Dee
said he doesn't typically play
breakpoint like a survival game he does
set the Tactical difficulty to Elite at
least is a starting point this means
bandages are limited risk of injury is
set to always stamina consumption is
Extreme health does not regenerate and
ammo is lost on reloads additionally
syringes don't heal injuries if that
wasn't enough darkest night mode is also
turned on meaning visibility is reduced
at night this hopefully will force us to
use our night vision goggles more okay
let's pause here for just one second I
need to emphasize that we're not trying
to make Ghost Recon breakpoint as hard
as possible instead we're trying to make
it the most tense tactical shooter it
can possibly be of course for some
people the fun is in making the overall
experience more punishing but for others
these settings promote that thoughtful
play style it's all about finding your
sweet spot so when you fire up
breakpoint to revisit it I suggest you
play around with these parameters and
see what fits your play style some of
these settings even lean more to the
survival aspect that gives more purpose
to some of breakpoint's more extraneous
mechanics like drinking water and
cooking
[Music]
oh
now a key component of every good
tactical shooter is difficulty and enemy
AI enemies should be aggressive
responsive and deadly this forces you to
play smart and think multiple steps
ahead if the AI lacks in any of these
areas the gameplay can devolve into a
super soldier shooting gallery which
isn't the Ghost Recon way the best
tactical Shooters reward careful
planning as much as quick judgment calls
and unfortunately even on break points
harder difficulties you can rip through
enemies and outposts without giving it
much of a second thought there's not a
lot of risk unless you are severely
underprepared thankfully the Ghost Recon
Community has already addressed this
issue with the Spartan mode mod one of
the coolest things it does is it beefs
up the perception of the enemy AI which
I think that a lot of people who have
played on Extreme for long enough will
complain that the AI don't really
respond as much as they should to things
going on around them this mod isn't
technically a new difficulty mode the
modder who goes by Van andar describes
it as a rebalancing that tweaks enemy
Behavior this mod also makes it
particularly difficult to take down a
base during the daytime which makes
sense since they'll have better
visibility during the day vandar
recommends setting the enemy difficulty
to the second hardest difficulty Advance
rapid in the hardest Elite given the
ai's improved awareness elite can be
particularly brutal borderlining on
unfair when you load up breakpoint after
making all of these changes it feels
like a very different game and in a
sense it is the minimal HUD forces you
to pay more attention to your
surroundings and listen for nearby
threats the inability to Mark enemies
requires you to keep a mental map of the
area information typically available to
the player is stripped away so that the
Intel Gathering and strategic
considerations that Define the Ghost
Recon experience return to the
foreground it's impossible to know how
many foes are patrolling a point of
Interest unless you do some actual Ghost
Recon even the topography time of day
and weather needs to be considered when
you play This Way mountain ranges can
give you better sight lines to gather
information and pick off stray enemies
if you have the range while valleys
could leave you exposed in a precarious
position time of day especially with
darkest night mode enabled as well as
weather can also significantly hinder
your visibility which could be used to
your advantage if you take a stealthy
approach or a detriment if you allow the
mission to devolve into an all-out
uncontrolled firefight
foreign
reconnaissance and careful coordination
pays off in dividends when playing this
way planning and orchestrating a
successful attack based on your own
Intel that you had to uncover yourself
is incredibly satisfying it slows down
the overall pace of the game but it
makes encounters feel more meaningful
throughout that said I do think turning
off the HUD wholesale can be pretty
off-putting especially for those that
may not be familiar with all of ghost
recon's mechanics without pickup markers
you probably won't be able to tell loot
from environmental dressing and without
a detection indicator it can be very
hard to tell where an enemy spots you
from thankfully nearly every little HUD
detail can be customized I suggest
starting with light or minimal interface
presets and then customize from there as
you get more comfortable at the very
least I'd turn off the health bar ammo
counter and minimap the red vignette
makes it pretty obvious when you're low
on health and your character will limp
if they are injured if you leave
objective markers and waypoints on
however you can get by without the
mini-map entirely if you're playing
Co-op though you may want to leave the
compass on with a minimal HUD this makes
coordination more intense as it forces
you and your buddies to accurately call
out cardinal directions rather than
relying on red flips
while chatting with diff one thing he
said stuck out to me the ability to be
methodical be tactical just kind of
living out the fantasy of being you know
a special spec opposition I feel like
Ghost Recon lets you explore these
opportunities with your imagination a
bit more it's interesting that we have
that option to express a bit more of our
preferences our our own identity within
breakpoint I think what's most
surprising is that with all these
settings whether intentional or not
Elevate breakpoint Beyond an open world
tactical shooter it almost scratches a
role-playing itch that I never expected
in a game like Ghost Recon sure there's
different classes and skill trees but by
the end I had unintentionally created a
backstory and personality for my
character that informed my play style
it's rare to see this kind of
flexibility when it comes to Modern game
design but in the case of Ghost Recon
breakpoint it recontextualizes the
entire experience and therein lies the
beauty of breakpoint and also the point
of no HUD this show is about finding new
and interesting ways to play games Ghost
Recon breakpoint players were dealt a
bad hand when the game was released but
with the changes we've suggested you can
lay all its cards on the table rearrange
them and play with a deck of your own
creation Ghost Recon breakpoint is more
than just a pretty island with guns it's
a Sandbox brimming with possibility and
honestly the more I think about it I I
think it's safe to say that Ghost Recon
breakpoint earns the Tom Clancy Ghost
Recon name
thanks again for checking out this
episode of no HUD if there's games you'd
like to see us cover in the future make
sure to let us know in the comments
below and hey while you're down there
let me know how you play Ghost Recon
breakpoint I'd love to know I'll see you
next time
our kingdom is cursed oh
the prince has been kidnapped and taken
to a forbidden land
all hope rests with us the Immortals to
rescue him and save the empire
we weren't prepared for what was coming
next up so I can't say no
then again they weren't prepared for me
foreign
my
phone came with a purpose
to come
and these times of Darkness hope is the
only thing that keeps us fighting
I will fulfill my destiny and save the
kingdom
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armies Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and in
this week's episode Jonathan is taking
another look at some of the Weaponry
from Rainbow Six Siege so how does this
thing look I'm trying to try hard to
look past the lurid green grid pattern
and whatever the hell's going on with
the butt stock that looks like someone's
stubbed out three enormous cigars on it
no idea what's going on there if there
are any other games guns are mechanics
that you guys want to see Jonathan
breakdown let us know in the comment
section below and for something a little
bit different make sure to check out our
new series Mind Games a show that
explores the psychological impact of
gaming from our relationship loot boxes
to the psychology behind horror games
right time to check out more of the guns
of Rainbow Six Siege
we've got a nice good view from the side
and well that's not an AK-74 M or
otherwise so why is this not an ak-74m
well let's let's focus on what's right
so the magazine looks about right for
the earlier sort of plum colored mag
5.45 magazine the ammunition looked like
it could well be 5.45 so that's that's
fine the furniture is sudo Magpul we've
got some sort of optical Mount sight
Mount replacing the rear sight Leaf
which is a real thing that you can do on
AKs rather than putting on the top cover
we've got a absolutely huge akm style
slant compensator on the front that's
what it looks like gas block area well
and the top cover for that matter akm
pattern I had to compare with it with a
Romanian one to see if it's close but I
suspect it's a bit of a fudge because
all of that rambling boils down to this
is a sort of non-specific 5.45 caliber
AK it doesn't have the classic muzzle
break of an AK-74 the markings are
obvious wrong the receiver's not the
right quite the right shape it's the
wrong top cover for a 74 M and the
furniture is not 74n
there's some interesting ejection going
on on this thing I happen to have uh
paused here on what looks dangerously
close to a stoppage because we've got
some very some non-energetic ejection
shall we say and so this case is barely
making it out of the gun in time and of
course if it doesn't do that then the
bolt will trap it the classic sort of
stove pipe Jam is where you have a case
sticking out the action the Bolt's not
gone forward yeah so it's attempt it'll
attempt to pick up the next round but it
won't get it chambered because you've
got the previous one still sticking out
now that obviously hasn't happened
because it's not programmed in to do
that I sometimes pay attention to things
like ejection patterns and that just
stuck out for me and The Recoil is
probably okay it would depend very much
which muzzle device was fitted and this
appears to just be a generic bird cage
type flash suppressor which wouldn't
really have any effect on recoil
mitigation the traditional AK-74 muzzle
break is very effective this is behaving
more like it's got that on it
all right I don't remember the AMT Auto
mag being in this game because that's
what this is here is the AMT Auto mag I
can barely see over it it's huge so this
is the the 44 amp model 180 there are
different models but I do believe this
is the one that's being represented here
in Siege and you can see I think that
they have done
really quite a good job it's a very
distinctive looking pistol they could
have taken the Modern Warfare route and
made it look legally different or just
different for artistic reasons but they
haven't they have pretty Faithfully
represented the gun should they have
bothered well me as a tactical shooter
fan no I don't think they should have um
I don't think this has any place in a
game like this but that's just me being
an increasingly grumpy old man
Liberty on the ground floor
eliminated
I will say the magazine changes seem a
little bit slick for this this is
essentially a target pistol and it's
really from an era before rapid magazine
changes were a thing really so the the
magazine release is up here you'd need
thumbs like a bat that's that's probably
not even a good analogy but I'm going to
go with it to be able to reach that
button you'd have to really
realistically for a quick Magazine
change use your support hand thumb and
it's recessed quite quite heavily into
this grip as well so you've really got
to get in there and shove that and then
the magazine does not drop free you have
to rip that out take your classic
tactical reload is not so much a thing
on this
foreign
that's quite unusual not least because
it has what looks somewhat like an FN
gl40 grenade launcher on the bottom of
it not commonly seen on sniper rifles or
Precision rifles generally this is very
futuristic looking the grip is quite a
weird shape the stock isn't too unusual
for modern Precision rifles where they
have that skeletal look with various
adjustable features on them but I think
again I think that's an original design
too a very heavy barrel with a large
three-chambered muzzle break is it and
the 300 in the name I assume refers to
300 Win Mag not quite sure the
significance of the EXO on the side but
let's have a look
okay
so the under Barrel launcher I did
notice it had no visible rifling in the
ball is that an oversight or could it be
some sort of non-lethal thing but then I
also thought this is a sniper rifle
you're going to be at potentially 100
100 meters or something away well a
coupling lethal and non-lethal on the
same weapon is usually a bad idea and
secondly it's unlikely to have yeah the
range doesn't really match there but I
was edging the right direction because
this thing appears to be for battering
down doors boarded up windows that kind
of thing so you can then engage from
outside I suppose from a sort of SWAT
point of view yeah people think of
precision rifles as being 1000 yard or
whatever rifles and they can be but for
law enforcement very very unlikely
you're going to be going out Beyond even
100 meters to be honest with you you
need to be able to positively ID your
target you need to be able to maximize
the chance of hitting them if you do
have to open fire so it's not totally
beyond the Realms possibility that you
would would put some sort of device like
this on the same Weapon It's just highly
unlikely
foreign
with I know the designation I've seen it
before in pictures but this is a
relatively obscure released in the west
Russian pistol design so this this is I
don't know you can stare at it and try
and compare it to various Western
designs but it's kind of its own thing
it is just a pistol at the end of the
day it doesn't do anything particularly
special I'm sure the designers would
disagree with me there seeing it in use
there it's incredibly what some people
call flat shooting which doesn't refer
to the trajectory of the bullet that
what they mean is the muzzle stays level
when you shoot and The Recoil is as
straight back as possible now that's a
function of the the caliber the design
of the pistol and more than anything
else the position hold of the shooter
and the wrist and arm strength as well
to be fair but some things are flatter
shooting than others and I don't know if
this is a fair representation but it's
extremely flat shooting too much so I
would say what you typically see with a
hat with a pistol is you'll get some
some muzzle rise but through a
combination of ergonomics and skill
those sites return to level on each shot
but they don't stay Rock Solid straight
the whole time unless you're shooting
something like a 2-2 pistol or 22 pistol
really
fast
I have got for you our only select fire
P90 we have a couple that are actually
in police trials and they're identical
and they're semi-auto only this one
goes up to 11 or rather to automatic
it's not labeled automatic interestingly
but it does in fact go there so how does
this thing look well I'm trying to hard
to try hard to look past the lurid green
grid pattern and whatever the hell's
going on with the butt stock that looks
like someone's stubbed out three
enormous cigars on it no idea what's
going on there the magazine looks a bit
melty I don't know if that's a skin or a
mistake but
the magazine looks like that it's quite
smooth a little bit of a textured finish
to it for grip yeah it's a it's a pretty
solid effort some of the angles don't
necessarily it's a it's a bit too flat
in various places so this four grip here
is iconically weird
curved foregrip actually has a sort of
triangle flat to it here and then it
goes full round basic basically in in
the game it's very flat all the way
around this is the level of detail we
have to look at guns with in this job I
suppose what I'm saying is it's a little
bit off but not really so you'd notice
unless you were staring at a real one
like I'm fortunate enough to do
now the Russian weapon we don't yet have
the pkp or passion egg 6p41 without
looking it up will be the Grau index
designation for this weapon which is
another good way to name a weapon in a
game without actually naming it for
whatever reason usually legal
interesting paint Scheme uh I can't
think that's standard with heavily
referencing the former Soviet Union I
think it's a good without having one to
show you pretty good effort on the pkp
which is as I think we've covered before
a sort of evolution of the PKM and this
one is the Bullpup kit version trigger
group is or is shunted forward and
making the whole thing a lot shorter but
keep preserving the barrel length that's
what a Bullpup is there may or may not
be a book on the subject
possible activity
friendly last operator standing
well I can't speak from direct
experience on how the pkp handles but
nothing leaps out as particularly weird
if you're going to assault with him with
a machine gun this one makes a lot of
sense it's got a heck of a lot of punch
it's nice and compact the balance will
let you keep better control of it firing
it whether from the hip or the shoulder
not usually the thing to do with a
belt-fed machine gun but it has been
known although having said that most
machine guns with the intent for this
kind of again assault purpose as it were
tends to be in smaller calibers for
better control
FN mini me or actually looks to be an
M249 specifically with that heat shield
handguard on the front just uh looking
at the reload there um I was a little
skeptical that they'd I thought they'd
fudge that a little bit by just
pressing on the mag catch but as you see
there you can in fact just tap it with
the thumb and that's enough to dislodge
it at which point you can just pull it
out so a more positive way to do it
would be to press and pull but the way
it's been done
by the player character is actually fine
so something that crops up quite a bit
with video game weapon design is you're
often working from even if you've had
access to the real thing you're often
working from 2D images maybe just a left
and right a worst case and so you tend
to miss details like this so this this
welded on
mounting lug on the front here on the
real gun
is actually
not just a solid tune it's a flat it's a
small diameter tube with flanges on it
and the bipod legs actually go Within
those flanges you can see it's sitting
inside
there there why am I going on about that
well these guys have they've got the
weld they've modeled the weld on the
tube really nicely but the actual tube
is solid and there's no way you could
fit a bipod to this even if you had a
handguard with a cutout to accept it
which they also don't now that's a big
deal because you would not ever use an
lmg or purchase an lmg that did not have
a bipod it's critical to its function
even if you think that you're going to
use it primarily as an assault type
weapon you're still gonna want the bipod
it's not worth getting rid of it
foreign
I don't normally comment too much on
tactics or ttps and stuff because I have
no known practical experience with it
and it's not my direct remit but I
couldn't help but smile at the hanging
off the side of a an uneven wall from
some sort of Mega repelling system that
is able to stay in place but also roll
across the top of the wall and actually
a bit unfair gameplay wise as well you
can basically stay in cover all the way
around the perimeter of the wall and
where it comes back to my relevance is
whilst also shoulder firing a light
machine gun and therefore having no
hands and just using your feet it's it's
very much action movie there but I've
never even in an action movie you won't
see free traversing repelling while
firing a machine gun I don't think or
not yet anyway you wouldn't be able to
pull that off in real life very easily
even for a stunt
all right this is another weird one very
strange it looks a lot like a an Ingram
based design now there is an Ingram
derived design from MasterPiece Arms in
the states that looks quite a bit like
this every detail is different but the
fact that the lower looks polymer and
the configuration of it the fact that
it's elongated the arrangement of the
cocking handle not being on top but
being on the side it's all quite
reminiscent of that design but strictly
speaking this is a fictional gun
we have got some astonishing recoil
there I'm not saying it's unrealistic
because if this thing is 9 mil by 19 and
fires it what sounds like 1000 rounds
plus per minute then it may well be that
difficult to control that said we have
got a foregrip on there and with a bit
of skill I'd expect you to be able to
keep at least start with a burst that
would be on Target on a man-sized Target
or whatever this is whereas this is
wandering all over the shop as soon as
the as soon as the day pulls the
triggered basically so it seems like
they have programmed in quite a lot of
recoil to make up for the blistering
rate of fire absolutely typical of a
video game compact SMG slash machine
pistol to treat them that way otherwise
why would you use anything else
let's see
insert Jurassic Park reference here
because it's the good old smash 12. now
the first thing I noticed about this is
like ours this gun has the rotating
safety this is actually was actually
recalled it was a dangerous design that
I remember rightly could fire when you
rotated it to fire not ideal for a
safety catch the other thing that I
noticed right away
um now as far as I know the Spas 12 was
never made with an integral picatinny
rail which on this looks to be part of
the forging or the casting or whatever
this is meant to be in the game the real
real gun has nothing here same goes for
the heat shield now you could easily
attach a particular picatinny rail to
this heat shield guess that's how you
probably would do it if you were trying
to update this thing with a red dot
sight you wouldn't you'd leave the
receiver alone and you would use the
heat shield otherwise it looks pretty
good we even got a bit of wear and rust
on this thing so we do get this quite
distinctive wear pattern which is not
quite well represented on the heat
shield from the movement of this grip
because although I suspect in this game
it is semi only this was designed to be
either semi-automatic or pump action
meaning that you could load rounds that
wouldn't otherwise have enough energy to
operate the gun like breaching rounds
for example and that's done with a push
button under the pump grip which you
push down pull it back latch it into
place and that has now engaged with the
action bars effectively to turn it into
a pump action not that many shotguns
have that capability and but it's one
that's rarely represented in video games
because what would be the well I say
what would be the point I nearly did
there'd be every point in Siege because
in theory you could switch to breaching
rounds and have to use it as a pump
which means if you breach through the
door and you're left holding your
shotgun suddenly it would be a pump
action slower to operate gun firing less
damaging well arguably against body
armor less damaging rounds so that could
actually have been a gameplay feature
foreign
bit of an odyssey here well actually
it's an oddity in in the real gun world
just as it is in games I can't recall
having seen one before it is an AR well
would you call an AR-15 probably not AR
pattern shotgun hence it's massive and
chunky it follows the ergonomics the
basic design architecture of the AR-15
AR-10 series of rifles but it has a
massive thin wall Barrel a huge magazine
well and designed to take 12 gauge
shotgun cartridges but it will be
familiar in terms of operation to anyone
that's used an AR pattern rifle which is
a lot of people these days quite an
interesting interesting thing to be in
this game
um not aware of any serious users that
have adopted them there are too many
reasons I think to use other
self-loading shotguns for that type of
purpose very slick reload there with the
again the the bolt not holding open on
its own which is a surprise and then uh
flicking the gun back the other way to
send the mag flying out it looks cool is
it worth doing I don't know you'd best
ask us what team
right guys thank you for watching please
do if you can come and visit us here at
the Royal armories we have three sites
and different in different parts of the
country also our social media channels
and our own YouTube channel you can find
me and some more guns from The
Collection over on that as well as some
more interesting stuff coming along soon
that is not guns in any case thanks
again for joining us we'll see you next
week
welcome hidden one
[Music]
you have died and been Reborn
we need to find a way to get you inside
without being seen
you could bribe the guards to look the
other way I shall see what flavor best
suits me
[Music]
embrace the fear
quiet find a Stillness
let's go
the stage is yours passive
we will be watching
[Music]
thank you
Society has rules
everybody
it decides where you belong
and what you're worth
chart a new course
[Music]
foreign
do not give up
on the shores of a new world
you awaken
more determined than ever
to carve a life of your choice
fighting under our own flag we will take
what's ours
together
we will take on the world
Society may have rules
but today
side where you belong and what you're
worth
live as pawns or die as pirates
welcome to Silver Creek
a sweet little town in Middle America
you know the kind pumpkin patches apple
pies and the best damn cup of coffee
you'll ever have
Silver Creek was perfect up until it
wasn't
the green poison changed everything for
everyone
it started in New York on Black Friday
the biggest shopping day of the year
they called it the dollar flew because
it spread on money the virus knew No
Boundaries no matter where it hit the
bodies piled up and when it spread to
Silver Creek the result was the same
death
I'm division agent Mackenzie Reed
originally from Kansas I was stationed
in Boston when the [__] hit the fan
after Black Friday
I left Boston and came to Silver Creek
looking for Killian Tower my commander
well he was my commander until recently
for reasons unknown he disavowed the
division and is now a rogue agent
Killian betrayed my team and murdered
them
gun them down and fled no clues no
motive only a bloody Trail for me to
follow
that trail has led me to Silver Creek
I wasn't prepared for what I found I
wanted answers but all I got was more
questions why is the virus different
here
why did Killian murder the team he
proudly commanded and why is he amassing
an army of Reapers in Silver Creek
thing I've seen tells me that silver
Creeks at the heart of something big
I can't do this alone agent
I need your help
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
when we got the opportunity to work on
the next game of the series we sat down
with the rest of the Court team and husk
ourselves as fun what kind of Assassin's
Creed game we'd most want to play many
of us felt the desire to revisit some of
the old imagery narrative theme and
gameplays that made us fall in love with
the series after 15 years of Journeys
across the ages from the Third Crusade
with Altair to the Viking expansions
with Ivor we wanted to go back closely
to Where it All Began and pay homage to
the beginnings of Assassin's Creed
Comino valala we started to explore the
idea of introducing a new playable hero
Bassin and creating an experience that
is a love letter to the origins of the
franchise coming a fetch story with
revamp mechanics to bring the feel of
the early games into the modern day we
are going back to the Middle East but
this time in 9th century Baghdad 300
years before the time of Altair we are
telling the story of Basim and we became
a master assassin
we look at the first AC games and
started to wonder what exactly defined
the Assassin experience to us and from
there we put all our efforts into
bringing our Tech and the Assassin
fantasy
[Music]
to the experience with Baghdad as your
playground we are bringing the action
back to Urban environment for parkour we
look to our previous games for
inspiration and just to put the emphasis
on comfort and fluidity in Mirage Parker
is easy to learn and to master our
approach is closer to the SEO games
where it's all about keeping the flow
and the momentum going with the design
centered around verticality many
elements from past games are making a
return we have the current swing the
ability to Vault over objects elevators
to quickly reach high ground but also
new ingredients such as the pole vault
allowing you to cross large gaps between
two rooftops of course Basim is faster
and more agile than ever was and to keep
that feeling we worked on animations to
reinforce the sense of speed When
jumping vaulting and free roaming
streets are narrower denser and packed
with obstacles to navigate by choosing
the right pass through the environment
you can move from street level to the
rooftops in a blink of an eye a useful
skill for any assassin
[Music]
we want players to work in the shadows
plan their next move strike and then
vanish
there are more ways to assassinate with
new Killing animations some leveraging a
stealthy approach others delivering a
violent killing block we also have
direct Throwbacks to the first games
with moves like the bench assassination
that you might recognize from ac2 also
Kill from the rooftop gardens an old
favorite
we want to encourage you to be sneaky
bassim has been trained to fight by the
hidden ones but for him combat is a last
resort and his main approach is to hunt
and strike while remaining unnoticed we
also reworked our enemy AI to improve
detection and Vanishing Loops making our
behaviors more responsive and reasonable
new enemy archetypes will also increase
the stakes The Marksman can shoot your
ego and prevent you from using it the
Spearman pokes through Haystacks and own
Bearer can call for reinforcements
that's where your assassin skills come
in handy
during his training in alamut Basim
learns the ways of the Creed from his
mentor Roshan and his fellow hidden ones
we get to see him learn the tenets and
philosophies that will guide him through
his missions like hiding in plain sight
social stealth is making a return we are
bringing back the systemic blending with
larger crowds that all you to move
undetected through the business location
but you can also bribes more factions
with specific tokens in order to control
AI groups and make your way through
guarded areas
as a NASA senior Court mission is to
track down and eliminate the order of
the Ancients and free back that of their
influence in our game the hidden ones
have established a network of bureaus
across the city to keep an eye on the
order the bureaus in Mirage act as
gameplay Ebbs from which you can take on
site contracts with value subjectives
from rescue missions to assassinations
and LG Indian ones in their Fight For
Freedom we want you to feel truly
immersed in the life of a hidden one
investigating your Target's identities
tracking their movements and sharing
information with your lives then when
the time is right you can strike from
the Shadows we've crafted a new
investigation board which replaces our
most recent Quest log in Mirage and with
our Black Box missions we give you the
freedom to approach key assassination
missions however you see things we know
are excited our community is we also
have a nice surprise for our long timers
we implemented the nostalgic visual
filter as an option for those who wish
to explore the game with a desaturated
blue gray color palette from the very
first AC game
this is a project led by a team of
passionate people who have their very
own vision of the Assassin experience in
mind there is much to come and we can't
wait to unveil more about basim's
Journey
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the world of Avatar the James Cameron
and his team at lightstone brought to
life is epic in so many ways it's
brimming with life it's by luminescent
at night and it's Majestic in scale as
it is enriched in details
as the world of Avatar is so different
from anything we've done before we had
to do some major upgrades and big
improvements to our engine
in the past it's not up allowed us to
build amazing cities but to capture the
natural beauty of Andorra we needed to
push Snowdrop even further
we have created the Pandora that you can
experience from the deep dense jungles
on the ground to the Grand Vistas high
up in the skies so with Snowdrop using
the micro detail system we can propagate
thousands of assets in one frame this
allows us to have a lot more highly
detailed environment for Pandora for the
game we created a varied amount of
vegetation using automated placement and
this is significantly more objects than
we ever had before so by moving
visibility testing to the GPU we can now
process way more objects per frame so
the advantage of Snowdrop is that it can
handle quite complex shaders to add more
life to the vegetation of Pandora we
created many interactive shaders that
can be affected by the player from
real-time wind simulations and
interactions to intelligent plants
reacting to your presence we don't just
explore jungles on the ground we also
get to fly our Bunch so so we added a
new volumetric cloud system in Snowdrop
to improve the visual quality of our sky
with great facing we can now illuminate
Pandora in a way we never could before
this way we can have real light reflect
from the emission and the
bioluminescence coming out from the
plants making Pandora more vibrant and
more realistic real-time Ray tracing
allows us to greatly improve Lighting in
our game Ray traced Global illumination
and Reflections make our game appear
more naturally lit and more
materialistic there are Dynamic objects
Dynamic weather or time of day the
different activities that NPCs can
perform in the world and the different
animations they have can make the world
feel really alive so for Avatar Frontier
Pandora we wanted to take this one step
further and created a system where our
NPCs understand the state of the world
for example whether player progression
or time of day the teams at Ubisoft have
done a fantastic job improving Snowdrop
in every project we do we push the
engine further but Avatar Frontiers on
Pandora is without a doubt the biggest
leap we made so far and we believe it
will provide our players with a truly
immersive Avatar experience for the new
generation of hardware
Assassin's Creed is a 12 game series
featuring massive open worlds and tons
of hidden secrets with the recent
announcement of Assassin's Creed Mirage
a game set to hearken back to the
structure and design of the first
Assassin's Creed I think it would be
best to take the series back to its
roots these are 10 things you didn't
know about the original Assassin's Creed
number 10 half horse half man half
terrifying the horse in the original
Assassin's Creed is a handy and
trustworthy Steed to get you from City
to City I bet you didn't know that horse
was actually a man former Ubisoft
developer Charles Randall revealed that
because technical limitations at the
time only allowed for bipedal characters
they had to stretch out the model of an
in-game NPC and animated and rigged it
to move like a horse a similar
workaround was found for the character
of Malik whose missing arm was actually
a tiny scrunch up little arm inside his
sleeve
number nine assassins roll out when
traversing through the cities of
Damascus and acre there are sets of
window Arrangements that form the shape
of the front of G1 Optimus Prime in
truck form
number eight the sacred texts NPC
dialogue in acre has a civilian confused
as to which text he's quoting well the
Bible does say God helps those who help
themselves
nah it doesn't actually that's from one
of these Subs fables the Bible says
quite the opposite in fact many passages
of being patient and faithful are
waiting for the Lord to decide if he
wishes to assist well I say we've waited
long enough
[Music]
number seven assassin's couch Co-op
according to Julian merceron former
Ubisoft technical director the original
Assassin's Creed experimented with
having local multiplayer according to an
article an interview on dualshockers it
states that in fact there was a bug
while he doesn't know when it was
patched at some point if a second
controller was plugged into the console
a Second Assassin would appear on screen
the team didn't even test for those
features as they thought they were
disabled and that's how the bug appeared
although there aren't any other details
on what multiplayer would have looked
like multiplayer features wouldn't be
featured in another Assassin's Creed
until Assassin's Creed Brotherhood in
2012.
number six side missions smide missions
although modern day Assassin's Creed
games pack in a lot of side content I
mean I got Valhalla and launch day and I
still haven't cleared the map the
original Assassin's Creed didn't have
any until five days before release
Charles Randall detailed that the game
was ready to ship and had passed all
levels of scrutiny until the CEO's kid
got his hands on it the kid reported
that the game was boring and there was
nothing to do Randall's lead came to him
and proposed the idea to put inside
missions with the stipulation that we
have to put all these side missions in
the game in five days and they have to
be bug free because the build is going
to be burned directly to disc and
released to retail Randall described the
next five days as a blur the only
notable bug that remained in game from
the Frantic five-day stint is that one
of the Templars you're supposed to
assassinate falls through the geometry
and is unable to be accessed causing you
to restart your game to get a full gamer
score I think Randall puts it best
though I know it's a miracle that the
game just didn't melt your console
number five the Animus the fictional
device that allows Desmond to travel
into his ancestors genetic memories is
called the Animus this is a direct
reference to part of the collective
unconscious Theory by cycle analyst Carl
Young described the Animus as the
unconscious masculine side of a woman
and the enema as the unconscious
feminine side of a man each transcending
the personal psyche although not
specific to just Assassin's Creed 2007 a
number of the female characters
throughout the greater series have names
relating to the stages of Anima
development as detailed by Young Eve
Maria auditory de ferenze and Sophia
Sartor just to name a few
[Music]
number four multilingual one of the many
real-life historical figures you run
into during your time in the holy land
is Richard the first commonly known as
Richard the lionheart during your
interaction all of his dialogue is
spoken with a French accent
are stronger in their convictions
although the king of England at the time
Richard spent most of his life in the
anjivan domains in France that would put
him on the modern day western side of
the country reinforced by his
appointment as duke Normandy
number three historical fiction when
creating the world of the first
Assassin's Creed the team at Ubisoft
looked to real-life historical figures
as well as works of fiction surrounding
the time of the Crusades to layer into
their storytelling the story of Altair's
order was inspired by the life of Hassan
isaba he is reputed as the founder of
the real-life order of Assassins known
as the Azari is Mali state or hashashan
and ruler of the mountain Fortress known
as alamut in turn alamut was used as the
title of a 1938 novel by Vladimir bartol
the novel is set entirely at The
Fortress of Alamos and follows a young
Soldier joining the ranks interacting
with Hassani Sabah frequently throughout
the siege of alamut by the selijuk
Empire The Assassin's Creed team at
Ubisoft used many of the plot points in
the novel as story threads throughout
the tale of Assassin's Creed the novel
also creates the famous main principle
of the Assassin's Brotherhood in the
novel it is stated by Hassani Sabah as
nothing is absolute reality all is
permitted in the game the motto is
tweaked to nothing is true Everything is
permitted Altair's Garb is also directly
pulled from the novel the timeline of
the game is not the same as the novel
however with Altair and the members of
his sect of hashashan existing during
the third crusade in 1191. Hassani Sabah
died in 1124.
number two on Eagles Wings Eagle imagery
pops up again and again throughout the
series but especially in the first
Assassin's Creed when designing the look
of Altair animator kaidenwin used a bird
of prey as the design concept the
original design had Altair in long
flowing robes but because of Hardware
limitations they created a much sleeker
feathered look for his garments obvious
Eagle inclusions are the eagle that
flies away when you mount a Viewpoint in
any of the major cities Eagle Vision and
the Aviary Screech when performing a
leap of faith but because the Assassin
was not supposed to be the main
character in the original concept of the
game he didn't have a name when the
Assassin role became the main focus of
the story they gave him the name Altair
which means the flying eagle in Arabic
number one Prince of Persia assassin
initial development for Assassin's Creed
started in 2004 as a Prince of Persia
game after the success of Sands of Time
Ubisoft tasked Prince of Persia director
Patrice desolate to Begin work on the
next game in the series for the very
mysterious seventh generation of
consoles in order to accomplish
something that would live up to the
intense hype surrounding the power of
the PS3 and Xbox 360. distillate ditched
the linear progression model of the
Prince of Persia levels and replaced it
with a vast open world set in the holy
land during the height of the Crusades
along with the massive scope the game
added huge crowds and easy parkour
access to every level of the three major
cities for the most immersion possible
to put it in perspective sands of time
could only allow for eight characters on
screen at any given time Assassin's
Creed allowed for 120 but after nearly
two years of development Ubisoft was not
ready to give over the project to a new
IP the game had you play as an assassin
bodyguard of The Prince and watch over
him through guided scenario in which
you'd have to use your skills to save
him or get him out of other perilous
situations so basically the entire game
was one big escort mission
hmm thankfully the prince character was
dropped and the Assassin's Creed evolved
into the game we know it as today
[Music]
Assassin's Creed defined what the open
world genre would look like for Ubisoft
during the past three console
Generations the series itself has gone
through some award-winning highs lows
that have made it a divisive series
throughout the gaming industry and a
reinvention that flipped the formula in
a fascinating way it's been enthralling
to go back to 2007 and see where the
series has come from along with the
thought and principle that went into its
world and story with the new entry in
the series Assassin's Creed Mirage
freshly announced an emphasis on a Back
to Basics mentality from Ubisoft will be
interesting to see how they execute it
within the framework of how different
Assassin's Creed looks and feels today
from its inception for more on
Assassin's Creed Mirage make sure you
subscribe to Gamespot check out our
Rockstar editor Jordan ramay's chat with
the art director of Assassin's Creed
Mirage come find me on Twitter at Stewie
reviewey and thanks for watching
welcome to soul and Bones our game takes
place during the Golden Age of piracy
and a world inspired by the beautiful
yet dangerous Indian Ocean you'll start
your journey as an outcast whose goal is
to become the most infamous pirate to
sail these treacherous Waters
thank you
after surviving a shipwreck you begin
your adventure in Saint Anne one of the
pirate dens in our world dens are
centers of pirate activity where you can
craft new ships and Equipment provision
for your Expeditions at Sea pick up
contracts and socialize with other
players
any pirate with their cell will tell you
that preparation is key to success
get ready for any challenges that come
your way by checking that your cargo is
stocked with items like food and
ammunition
once you're set it's time to head out
and explore
as a rookie pirate you'll only have
access to a small Dow but as you
progress you'll be able to craft
different ships each with their own
unique play style
at Sea you'll need to pay close
attention to the condition of your ship
and the morale of your crew your crew
are a pack of vicious Raiders and Rovers
who will Mutiny against you if not kept
well fed and happy
if your ship sinks you'll lose some
progress and respawn at the nearest
discover Den or Outpost
the good news is that most of your cargo
will be recovered and you'll have the
opportunity to retrieve the rest from
the wreckage but you'd better be quick
as other players can also steal it
as a pirate Captain your reputation is
everything and our game tracks this
through infamy the higher your infamy
the more opportunities you'll get one of
the many ways to grow your infamy is to
take up contracts these are deals that
you can make with other pirates in the
world contracts can have great rewards
if you're successful or costs if you
fail
you can also gain infamy by completing
other activities such as exploration
plundering treasure hunts investigations
Dynamic events and much more you can
undertake these either Solo or with
other players the world of skull and
bones is filled with riches and
resources that you'll be able to gather
as you explore
lagoons and rivers are teeming with
dangerous wildlife that you can hunt for
animal skins and meat you'll also be
able to harvest a variety of raw
materials such as ore and wood that can
be refined and used for crafting
crafting is an essential activity for
you to progress as an Infamous pirate
obtain Blueprints and use your refined
resources to craft stronger ships
weapons and armors
in Skull and Bones ships serve many
different purposes cargo ships are
slower but useful if you need to
transport large volumes of loot
navigation ships sail faster but have
less cargo space and lower Hull HP
Firepower ships have more gun ports
allowing you to deal higher damage but
are more challenging to maneuver
similarly you can craft a wide array of
unique weapons and armors from Greek
fires to Giant ballista to rocket
launchers and mortars as well as
different armor types which have varying
strengths and weaknesses against
incoming attacks
with your new Fleet and growing Arsenal
create a Loadout based on your personal
play style to become a force of
Destruction
in the open ocean opportunities and
threats are abundant use your Spyglass
to identify lucrative trade routes or
wealthy Merchant ships and assess your
praise cargo and Firepower
strategize a plan of attack based on
your opponent's defenses and take
advantage of their weak points to deal
more damage
sinking your foes from afar rewards you
with only a portion of their cargo as
some of it will be lost to the depths
getting in close to execute a boarding
maneuver will help maximize your gains
but beware you can turn from Predator to
prey in a heartbeat if you attract The
Unwanted attention of privateers the
merciless pirate Hunters that Patrol the
seeds if you enjoy the thrill of the
hunt you can also seek out other players
and Reign Terror on them such PVP
battles are high-stakes activities that
can be rewarding if you emerge
Victorious
from your Spoils of battle personalize
your individual look with outfits that
command respect
[Music]
you can also select from a multitude of
ship customization options to instill
fear in your enemies
With The Wind in your sails Journey to
the furthest reaches of the Indian Ocean
from the coast of Africa to the East
Indies
encounter extreme weather events like
violent storms and monstrous roadways
keep your eyes peeled for outposts which
are safe spots where you'll be able to
dock your ship for a short rest from the
perilous Seas here you can trade with
traveling merchants and clandestine
Smugglers selling rare and illegal Goods
uncover buried bounties at outposts as
you decipher treasure maps obtained
through your voyages although all the
content and skull and bones can be done
solo you might enjoy ruling the Seas
with your friends while sailing you can
also easily invite other Pirates you
encounter to group up synergize your
different play Styles ships and weapons
to defeat deadlier enemies
as you grow stronger take on more
difficult challenges such as attacking
Forts and plundering settlements and if
you're bold enough engage in Dynamic
events like taking down heavily Laden
Merchant ships and their Fleet of
Warship escorts
now it's up to you to write your own
story remember there is no one path to
follow no one way to play the world of
skull and bones is yours to discover
these are dangerous times
at least that's what I hear
the empire
[Music]
they're everywhere
but the world here
belongs to syndicates
[Music]
I want to survive
I have to play their game
looks like I'm all in
she's in here somewhere one second
thought I'm out
foreign
[Music]
and now
I just need a chance to finally be free
[Music]
wherever that takes me
I'm here to offer you a way out okay
get off my ship Jalen give me a chance
you're gonna have to trust me you'll be
dangerous risky but if you pull this off
you'll never look over your shoulder
again
[Music]
the underworld shows no mercy
but it's a big Galaxy out there and I'm
gonna risk it off
[Music]
Star Wars Outlaws coming to
bless him at nurse Hall
are you ready to give up who you once
thought you were I am
[Music]
[Applause]
ready to sacrifice everything your
health clothes I am
[Music]
what happened
are you ready to leave your life behind
and watch the path of Shadows I am
foreign
[Music]
you will return to the dark
never forget the tenets you have sworn
to uphold
[Music]
say your blade from the Flesh of the
innocent
hide in plain sights
never compromise the Brotherhood
what happened
[Music]
from this day forward
you are a hidden one
[Music]
thank you
Assassin's Creed Mirage coming 2023
foreign
ly so but what if I told you in the five
years since release it has become one of
the best Ghost Recon games of all time
and an excellent open world game hello
and welcome to Gamespot no HUD the show
where we take a look at some of your
favorite games and tweak the settings
just enough to create a brand new
experience today we're taking a look at
Ghost Recon breakpoint and we're going
to turn this into the Tactical tense
shooter that we all wanted now this is
going to be a tough Mission so we've
recruited deep Ghost Recon expert to
guide us along the way
thank you
break point built upon 2017's Ghost
Recon wildlands as another open world
Ghost Recon game however instead of
refining its Co-op sandbox and the
Tactical opportunities it presented
breakpoint buried those core ideas under
a loot-based shooter with color-coded
loot gear scores and even raids yes they
put raids in a ghost recon game while
the moment-to-moment gameplay was nearly
identical to wildlands the blue grind
not only compromised the identity of
Ghost Recon but also poisoned the entire
experience for many the pitch was a
tactical shooter with survival mechanics
some of which were interesting others of
which felt underdeveloped the delivery
however was an underwhelming Ghost Recon
game that abandoned ITS Tactical roots
in favor of chasing Trends with a poorly
implemented live surface model it was a
disaster from top to bottom but this is
a Redemption story
so how do we turn this mess into one of
the best tactical Shooters on the market
we'll take you through the process to
show you how we'll be incorporating
tweaks and new features that ubisoft's
own patches introduced before taking
matters into our own hands with a mod
that is going to rework The Experience
significantly and will have deep explain
what the impact of this is together
I got him thankfully Ubisoft did some of
the heavy lifting back in 2020 when it
introduced something called ghost
experience parameters yes it's really
called ghost experience parameters this
update allowed players to hop in the
settings menu and rebalance the entire
game in a matter of seconds more
importantly you can even turn off the
terrible gear score and loot system
altogether which we're gonna do right
now I've got nothing against loot
systems I've played my fair share of
Destiny and they can offer a rewarding
Loop but they don't belong in a ghost
recon game what Elite operative is
constantly changing their clothes and
tossing away equipment for new ones that
incrementally make them feel more
powerful none the answer is none so
where do we go from here well this is
where deep comes in he's put in over 600
hours in breakpoint and he doesn't just
play this game he makes it sing
it has to be extreme I have the Tactical
difficulty put up to Elite and the
interface the whole HUD is pretty much
nothing I don't have Anna hang up except
for the objective that I'm going to just
because if I don't have guided mode on I
will go on the tangent and I will get
lost it's pretty much Bare Bones zero
HUD and just a little bit of guidance
from the game well this show is called
no HUD so I guess it makes sense just to
turn basically everything off like Steve
said the only thing I'm going to leave
on are the objective markers so I don't
get lost or distracted however when
watching Deep's gameplay I did notice
one important HUD element missing
reticles yeah no Crosshair which was a
learning experience but I feel like the
more I play it I'm looking for more and
more of a challenge and to be more
immersed and yeah across hair was
breaking the immersion for me at a
little bit so I got rid of it this may
seem daunting even a bit absurd for a
third person shooter with
over-the-shoulder aiming but breakpoint
provides you with the tools to overcome
this the obvious choice is to turn off
over the shoulder aiming altogether this
means that aiming will default to iron
sights and Scopes if you prefer the
over-the-shoulder style of aiming you
can track down a laser sight that said
if you've never played breakpoint before
I don't recommend turning everything off
right out of the gate now the gameplay
experience will be predominantly defined
by the Tactical difficulty menu here you
can tweak a wide range of settings that
can fundamentally change the game the
biggest example of this is gear score
which we've already turned off while Dee
said he doesn't typically play
breakpoint like a survival game he does
set the Tactical difficulty to Elite at
least is a starting point this means
bandages are limited risk of injury is
set to always stamina consumption is
Extreme health does not regenerate and
ammo is lost on reloads additionally
syringes don't heal injuries if that
wasn't enough darkest night mode is also
turned on meaning visibility is reduced
at night this hopefully will force us to
use our night vision goggles more okay
let's pause here for just one second I
need to emphasize that we're not trying
to make Ghost Recon breakpoint as hard
as possible instead we're trying to make
it the most tense tactical shooter it
can possibly be of course for some
people the fun is in making the overall
experience more punishing but for others
these settings promote that thoughtful
play style it's all about finding your
sweet spot so when you fire up
breakpoint to revisit it I suggest you
play around with these parameters and
see what fits your play style some of
these settings even lean more to the
survival aspect that gives more purpose
to some of breakpoint's more extraneous
mechanics like drinking water and
cooking
oh
now a key component of every good
tactical shooter is difficulty and enemy
AI enemies should be aggressive
responsive and deadly this forces you to
play smart and think multiple steps
ahead if the AI lacks in any of these
areas the gameplay can devolve into a
super soldier shooting gallery which
isn't the Ghost Recon way the best
tactical Shooters reward careful
planning as much as quick judgment calls
and unfortunately even on break points
harder difficulties you can rip through
enemies and outposts without giving it
much of a second thought there's not a
lot of risk unless you are severely
underprepared thankfully the Ghost Recon
Community has already addressed this
issue with the Spartan mode mod one of
the coolest things it does is it beefs
up the perception of enemy AI which I
think that a lot of people who have
played on Extreme for long enough will
complain that the AI don't really
respond as much as they should to things
going on around them this mod isn't
technically a new difficulty mode the
modder who goes by andar describes it as
a rebalancing that tweaks enemy Behavior
this mod also makes it particularly
difficult to take down a base during the
daytime which makes sense since they'll
have better visibility during the day
vandar recommends setting the enemy
difficulty to the second hardest
difficulty Advance rather than the
hardest Elite given the ai's improved
awareness elite can be particularly
brutal borderlining on unfair when you
load up breakpoint after making all of
these changes it feels like a very
different game and in a sense it is the
minimal HUD forces you to pay more
attention to your surroundings and
listen for nearby threats the inability
to Mark enemies requires you to keep a
mental map of the area information
typically available to the player is
stripped away so that the Intel
Gathering and strategic considerations
that Define the Ghost Recon experience
return to the foreground it's impossible
to know how many foes are patrolling a
point of Interest unless you do some
actual Ghost Recon even the topography
time of day and weather needs to be
considered when you play This Way
mountain ranges can give you better
sight lines to gather information and
pick off stray enemies if you have the
range while valleys could leave you
exposed and in a precarious position
time of day especially with darkest
night mode enabled as well as weather
can also significantly hinder your
visibility which could be used to your
advantage if you take a stealthy
approach or a detriment if you allow the
mission to devolve into an all-out
uncontrolled firefight
foreign
reconnaissance and careful coordination
pays off in dividends when playing this
way planning and orchestrating a
successful attack based on your own
Intel that you had to uncover yourself
is incredibly satisfying it slows down
the overall pace of the game but it
makes encounters feel more meaningful
throughout that said I do think turning
off the HUD wholesale can be pretty
off-putting especially for those that
may not be familiar with all of ghost
recon's mechanics without pickup markers
you probably won't be able to tell loot
from environmental dressing and without
a detection indicator it can be very
hard to tell where an enemy spots you
from thankfully nearly every little HUD
detail can be customized I suggest
starting with light or minimal interface
presets and then customize from there as
you get more comfortable at the very
least I'd turn off the health bar ammo
counter and minimap the red vignette
makes it pretty obvious when you're low
on health and your character will limp
if they are injured if you leave
objective markers and waypoints on
however you can get by without the
mini-map entirely if you're playing
Co-op though you may want to leave the
compass on with a minimal HUD this makes
coordination more intense as it forces
you and your buddies to accurately call
out cardinal directions rather than
relying on red flips
[Music]
while chatting with diff one thing he
said stuck out to me the ability to be
methodical be tactical just kind of
living out the fantasy of being you know
a special spec opposition I feel like
Ghost Recon lets you explore these
opportunities with your imagination a
bit more it's interesting that we have
that option to express a bit more of our
preferences our our own identity within
breakpoint I think what's most
surprising is that with all these
settings whether intentional or not
Elevate breakpoint Beyond an open world
tactical shooter it almost scratches a
role-playing itch that I never expected
in a game like Ghost Recon sure there's
different classes and skill trees but by
the end I had unintentionally created a
backstory and personality for my
character that informed my play style
it's rare to see this kind of
flexibility when it comes to Modern game
design but in the case of Ghost Recon
breakpoint it recontextualizes the
entire experience and therein lies the
beauty of breakpoint and also the point
of no HUD this show is about finding new
and interesting ways to play games Ghost
Recon breakpoint players were dealt a
bad hand when the game was released but
with the changes we've suggested you can
lay all its cards on the table rearrange
them and play with the deck of your own
creation Ghost Recon breakpoint is more
than just a pretty island with guns it's
a Sandbox brimming with possibility and
honestly the more I think about it I
think it's safe to say that Ghost Recon
breakpoint earns the Tom Clancy Ghost
Recon name
thanks again for checking out this
episode of no HUD if there's games you'd
like to see us cover in the future make
sure to let us know in the comments
below and hey while you're down there
let me know how you play Ghost Recon
breakpoint I'd love to know I'll see you
next time
our kingdom is cursed
the prince has been kidnapped and taken
to a forbidden land
all hope rests with us the Immortals to
rescue him and save the empire
we weren't prepared for what was coming
next up so I can't say no
then again they weren't prepared for me
came with a purpose now I'm about to
turn it down
don't take a chance
of Darkness hope is the only thing that
keeps us fighting
I will fulfill my destiny and save the
kingdom
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armies Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and in
this week's episode Jonathan is taking
another look at some of the Weaponry
from Rainbow Six Siege so how does this
thing look I'm trying to try hard to
look past the lurid green grid pattern
and whatever the hell's going on with
the butt stock that looks like someone's
stubbed out three enormous cigars on it
no idea what's going on there if there
are any other games going to mechanics
that you guys want to see Jonathan
breakdown let us know in the comment
section below and for something a little
bit different make sure to check out our
new series Mind Games a show that
explores the psychological impact of
gaming from a relationship with loot
boxes to the psychology behind horror
games right time to check out more of
the guns of Rainbow Six Siege
we've got a nice good view from the side
and well that's not an AK-74 M or
otherwise so why is this not an ak-74m
well let's let's focus on what's right
so the magazine looks about right for
the earlier sort of plum colored mag
5.45 magazine the ammunition looked like
it could well be 5.45 so that's that's
fine the furniture is sudo Magpul we've
got some sort of optical Mount sight
Mount replacing the rear sight Leaf
which is a real thing that you can do on
AKs rather than putting on the top cover
we've got a absolutely huge akm style
slant compensator on the front or that's
what it looks like gas block area well
and the top cover for that matter akm
pattern I had to compare with it with a
Romanian one to see if it's close but I
suspect it's a bit of a fudge because
all of that rambling boils down to this
is a sort of non-specific 5.45 caliber
AK it doesn't have the classic muzzle
break of an AK-74 the markings are
obviously wrong the receiver's not the
right quite the right shape it's the
wrong top cover for a 74 M and the
furniture is not 74n
foreign
going on on this thing I happen to have
uh paused here on what looks dangerously
close to a stoppage because we've got
some very some non-energetic ejection
shall we say and so this case is barely
making it out of the gun in time and of
course if it doesn't do that then the
bolt will trap it the classic sort of
stove pipe Jam is where you have a case
sticking out the action the Bolt's not
gone forward yeah so it's attempt it'll
attempt to pick up the next round but it
won't get it chambered because you've
got the previous one still sticking out
now that obviously hasn't happened
because it's not programmed in to do
that I sometimes pay attention to things
like ejection patterns and that just
stuck out for me and The Recoil is
probably okay it would depend very much
which muzzle device was fitted and this
appears to just be a generic bird cage
type flash suppressor which wouldn't
really have any effect on recoil
mitigation the traditional AK-74 muzzle
break is very effective this is behaving
more like it's got that on it
all right I don't remember the AMT Auto
mag being in this game because that's
what this is here is the AMT Auto mag I
can barely see over it it's huge so this
is the the 44 amp model 180 there are
different models but I do believe this
is the one that's being represented here
in Siege and you can see I think that
they have done
really quite a good job it's a very
distinctive looking pistol they could
have taken the Modern Warfare route and
made it look legally different or just
different for artistic reasons but they
haven't they have pretty Faithfully
represented the gun should they have
bothered well me as a tactical shooter
fan no I don't think they should have um
I don't think this has any place in a
game like this but that's just me being
you could bribe the guards to look the
other way
I shall see what flavor best suits me
[Music]
embrace the fear
quiet find the Stillness
and let's go
oh this stage is your spasm
we will be watching
[Music]
Society has rules
it decides where you belong
and what you're worth
foreign
[Music]
do not give up
on the shores of a new world
you awaken
more determined than ever
to carve a life of your choice
fighting under our own flag we will take
what's ours
foreign
Society may have rules
but today
you decide where you belong and what
you're with
will you live as pawns or die as pirates
please
welcome to Silver Creek a sweet little
town in Middle America
you know the kind pumpkin patches apple
pies and the best damn cup of coffee
you'll ever have
Silver Creek was perfect up until it
wasn't
the green poison changed everything for
everyone
started in New York on Black Friday the
biggest shopping day of the year they
called it the dollar flew because it
spread on money the virus knew No
Boundaries no matter where it hit the
bodies piled up and when it spread to
Silver Creek the result was the same
death
I'm division agent Mackenzie Reed
originally from Kansas I was stationed
in Boston when the [__] hit the fan
after Black Friday
[Music]
I left Boston and came to Silver Creek
looking for Killian Tower my commander
well he was my commander until recently
for reasons unknown he disavowed the
division and is now a rogue agent
Killian betrayed my team and murdered
them
gun them down and fled no clues no
motive only a bloody Trail for me to
follow
that trail has led me to Silver Creek
I wasn't prepared for what I found I
wanted answers but all I got was more
questions why is the virus different
here why did Killian murder the team he
proudly commanded and why is he amassing
an army of Reapers in Silver Creek
I've seen tells me that silver Creeks at
the heart of something big
I came through this alone agent
I need your help
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
when we got the opportunity to work on
the next game of the series we sat down
with the rest of the Court team and husk
ourselves as fun what kind of Assassin's
Creed game we'd most want to play many
others felt the desire to revisit some
of the old imagery narrative theme and
gameplays that made us fall in love with
the series after 15 years of Journeys
across the ages from the Third Crusade
with Altair to the Viking expansions
with Ivor we wanted to go back closely
to Where it All Began and pay homage to
the beginnings of Assassin's Creed
we started to explore the idea of
introducing a new playable hero Basin
and creating an experience that is a
love letter to the origins of the
franchise coming a fetch story with
Riven mechanics to bring the feel of the
early games into the modern day we are
going back to the Middle East but this
time in 9th century Baghdad 300 years
before the time of Altair we are telling
the story of Basim and we became a
master assassin
we look at the first AC games and
started to wonder what exactly defined
the Assassin experience to us and from
there we put all our efforts into
bringing our track and the Assassin
fantasy
[Music]
is a key pillar to the experience with
Baghdad as your playground we are
bringing the action back to Urban
environment for parkour we look to our
previous games for inspiration and just
to put the emphasis on comfort and
fluidity in Mirage Parker is easy to
learn and to master our approach is
closer to the SEO games where it's all
about keeping the flow and the momentum
going with the design centered around
verticality many elements from past
games are making a return we have the
current swing the ability to Vault over
objects elevators to quickly reach high
ground but also new ingredients such as
the pole vault allowing you to cross
large gaps between two rooftops of
course Basim is faster and more agile
than ever was and to give that feeling
we worked our animations to enforce the
sense of speed When jumping vaulting and
free roaming streets are now lower
denser and packed with obstacles to
navigate by choosing the right pass
through the environment you can move
from street level to the rooftops in a
blink of an eye a useful skill for any
assassin
[Music]
we want players to work in the shadows
plan their next move strike and then
vanish
there are more ways to assassinate with
new Killing animations some leveraging a
stealthy approach others delivering a
violent killing blood
we also have direct Throwbacks to the
first games with moves like the bench
assassination that you might recognize
from ac2 also Kill from the rooftop
gardens an old favorite
we want to encourage you to be sneaky
bassim has been trained to fight by the
hidden ones but for him combat is a last
resort and his main approach is to hunt
and strike while remaining unnoticed we
also reworked our enemy AI to improve
detection and Vanishing Loops making
guard behaviors more responsive and
readable
new enemy archetypes will also increase
the stakes The Marksman can shoot your
ego and prevent you from using it the
Spearman pokes through Haystacks and own
Bearer can call for reinforcements
that's where your assassin skills come
in handy
during his training in alamut Basim
learns the ways of the Creed from his
mentor Roshan and his fellow hidden ones
we get to see him learn the tenets and
philosophies that will guide him through
his missions like hiding in plain sight
social stealth is making a return we are
bringing back the systemic blending with
larger crowds that all you to move
undetected through the business location
but you cannot survives more factions
with specific tokens in order to control
AI groups and make your way through
guarded areas
as a NASA senior Court mission is to
track down and eliminate the order of
the Ancients and free back that of their
influence in our game the hidden ones
have established a network of bureaus
across the city to keep an eye on the
order the bureaus in Mirage act as
gameplay apps from which you can take on
site contracts with value subjectives
from rescue missions to assassinations
and LG Indian ones in their Fight For
Freedom we want you to feel truly
immersed in the life of a hidden one
investigating your Target's identities
tracking their movements and sharing
information with your lives then when
the time is right you can strike from
the Shadows we've crafted a new
investigation board which replaces our
most recent Quest log in Mirage and with
our Black Box missions we give you the
freedom to approach key assassination
missions however You See Fields we know
are excited our community is we also
have a nice surprise for our long timers
we implemented the nostalgic visual
filter as an option for those who wish
to explore the game with a desaturated
blue gray color palette from the very
first AC game
this is a project led by a team of
passionate people who have their very
own vision of the Assassin experience in
mind there is much to come and we can't
wait to unveil more about basim's
Journey
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the James Cameron and his team at
lightstone brought to life is epic in so
many ways experiment with life it's by
luminescent at night and it's Majestic
in scale as it is enriched in details
as the world of Avatar is so different
from anything we've done before we had
to do some major upgrades and big
improvements to our engine
in the past it's not up allowed us to
build amazing cities but to capture the
natural beauty of Pandora we needed to
push Snowdrop even further
we have created a Pandora that you can
experience from the deep dense jungles
on the ground to the Grand Vistas high
up in the skies so with Snowdrop using
the micro detail system we can propagate
thousands of assets in one frame this
allows us to have a lot more highly
detailed environment for Pandora for the
game we created a varied amount of
vegetation using automated placement and
this is significantly more objects than
we ever had before so by moving
visibility testing to the GPU we can now
process way more objects per frame so
the advantage of Snowdrop is that it can
handle quite complex shaders to add more
life to the vegetation of Pandora we
created many interactive shaders that
can be affected by the player from
real-time wind simulations and
interactions to intelligent plants
reacting to your presence we don't just
explore jungles on the ground we also
get to fly our Bunch so so we added a
new volumetric cloud system in Snowdrop
to improve the visual quality of our sky
with great facing we can now illuminate
Pandora in a way we never could before
this way we can have real light reflect
from the emission and the
bioluminescence coming out from the
plants making Pandora more vibrant and
more realistic real-time Ray tracing
allows us to greatly improve Lighting in
our game Ray traced Global illumination
and Reflections make our game appear
more naturally lit and more
photorealistic even when there are
Dynamic objects Dynamic weather or time
of day the different activities that
NPCs can perform in the world and the
different animations they have can make
the world feel really alive so for
Avatar frontiers of Pandora we wanted to
take this one step further and created a
system where our NPCs understand the
state of the world for example weather
player progression or time of day the
teams at Ubisoft have done a fantastic
job improving Snowdrop in every project
we do we push the engine further but the
Avatar Frontiers on Pandora is without a
doubt the biggest leap we made so far
and we believe it will provide our
players with a truly immersive Avatar
experience for the new generation of
hardware
foreign
Assassin's Creed is a 12 game series
featuring massive open worlds and tons
of hidden secrets with the recent
announcement of Assassin's Creed Mirage
a game set to hearken back to the
structure and design of the first
Assassin's Creed I think it would be
best to take the series back to its
roots these are 10 things you didn't
know about the original Assassin's Creed
number 10 half horse half man half
terrifying the horse in the original
Assassin's Creed is a handy and
trustworthy Steed to get you from City
to City I bet you didn't know that horse
was actually a man former Ubisoft
developer Charles Randall revealed that
because technical limitations at the
time only allowed for bipedal characters
they had to stretch out the model of an
in-game NPC and animated and rigged it
to move like a horse a similar
workaround was found for the character
of Malik whose missing arm was actually
a tiny scrunch up little arm inside his
sleeve
number nine assassins roll out when
traversing through the cities of
Damascus and acre there are sets of
window Arrangements that form the shape
of the front of G1 Optimus Prime in
truck form
foreign
the sacred texts NPC dialogue in acre
has a civilian confused as to which text
he's quoting well the Bible does say God
helps those who help themselves
nah it doesn't actually that's from one
of these substables the Bible says quite
the opposite in fact many passages of
being patient and faithful and waiting
for the Lord to decide if he wishes to
assist well I say we've waited long
enough
[Music]
number seven assassin's couch Co-op
according to Julian merceron former
Ubisoft technical director the original
Assassin's Creed experimented with
having local multiplayer according to an
article and interview on dualshockers it
states that in fact there was a bug
while he doesn't know when it was
patched at some point if a second
controller was plugged into the console
a Second Assassin would appear on screen
the team didn't even test for those
features as they thought they were
disabled and that's how the bug appeared
although there aren't any other details
on what multiplayer would have looked
like multiplayer features wouldn't be
featured in another Assassin's Creed
until Assassin's Creed Brotherhood in
2012.
number six side missions smide missions
although modern day Assassin's Creed
games pack in a lot of side content I
mean I got Valhalla and launch day and I
still haven't cleared the map the
original Assassin's Creed didn't have
any until five days before release
Charles Randall detailed that the game
was ready to ship and had passed all
levels of scrutiny until the CEO's kid
got his hands on it the kid reported
that the game was boring and there was
nothing to do Randall's lead came to him
and proposed the idea to put inside
missions with the stipulation that we
have to put all these side missions in
the game in five days and they have to
be bug free because the build is going
to be burned directly to disc and
released to retail Randall described the
next five days as a blur the only
notable bug that remained in game from
the Frantic five-day stint is that one
of the Templars you're supposed to
assassinate falls through the geometry
and is unable to be accessed causing you
to restart your game to get a full gamer
score I think Randall puts it best
though I know it's a miracle that the
game just didn't melt your console
number five the Animus the fictional
device that allows Desmond to travel
into his ancestors genetic memories is
called the Animus this is a direct
reference to part of the collective
unconscious Theory by cycle analyst Carl
Young described the Animus as the
unconscious masculine side of a woman
and the enema as the unconscious
feminine side of a man each transcending
the personal psyche although not
specific to just Assassin's Creed 2007 a
number of the female characters
throughout the greater series have names
relating to the stages of Anima
development as detailed by Young Eve
Maria Auditore de ferenze and Sophia
Sartor just to name a few
number four multilingual one of the many
real-life historical figures you run
into during your time in the holy land
is Richard the first commonly known as
Richard the lionheart during your
interaction all of his dialogue is
spoken with a French accent oh yes a
great favor indeed
now our enemies will be that much
stronger in their convictions although
the king of England at the time Richard
spent most of his life in the anjivan
domains in France that would put him on
the modern day western side of the
country reinforced by his appointment as
duke of Normandy
number three historical fiction when
creating the world of the first
Assassin's Creed the team at Ubisoft
looked to real-life historical figures
as well as works of fiction surrounding
the time of the Crusades to layer into
their storytelling the story of Altair's
order was inspired by the life of Hassan
isaba he is reputed as the founder of
the real life order of Assassins known
as the Azari ismali state or hashashan
and ruler of the mountain Fortress known
as alamut in turn alamut was used as the
title of a 1938 novel by Vladimir bartol
the novel is set entirely at The
Fortress of Alamos and follows a young
Soldier joining the ranks interacting
with Hassani Sabah frequently throughout
the siege of alamut by the selijuk
Empire The Assassin's Creed team at
Ubisoft used many of the plot points in
the novel as story threads throughout
the tale of Assassin's Creed the novel
also creates the famous main principle
of the Assassin's Brotherhood in the
novel it is stated by Hassani Sabah as
nothing is absolute reality all is
permitted in the game the motto is
tweaked to nothing is true Everything is
permitted Altair's Garb is also directly
pulled from the novel the timeline of
the game is not the same as the novel
however with Altair and the members of
his sect of hashashan existing during
the third crusade in 1191. Hassani Sabah
died in 1124.
number two on Eagles Wings Eagle imagery
pops up again and again throughout the
series but especially in the first
Assassin's Creed when designing the look
of Altair animator kaidenwin used a bird
of prey as the design concept the
original design had Altair in long
flowing robes but because of Hardware
limitations they created a much sleeker
feathered look for his garments obvious
Eagle inclusions are the eagle that
flies away when you mount a Viewpoint in
any of the major cities Eagle Vision and
the Aviary Screech when performing a
leap of faith but because the Assassin
was not supposed to be the main
character in the original concept of the
game he didn't have a name when the
Assassin role became the main focus of
the story they gave him the name Altair
which means the flying eagle in Arabic
number one Prince of Persia assassin
initial development for Assassin's Creed
started in 2004 as a Prince of Persia
game after the success of Sands of Time
Ubisoft tasked Prince of Persia director
Patrice desolate to Begin work on the
next game in the series for the very
mysterious seventh generation of
consoles in order to accomplish
something that would live up to the
intense hype surrounding the power of
the PS3 and Xbox 360. distillate ditched
the linear progression model of the
Prince of Persia levels and replaced it
with a vast open world set in the holy
land during the height of the Crusades
along with the massive scope the game
added huge crowds and easy parkour
access to every level of the three major
cities for the most immersion possible
to put it in perspective sands of time
could only allow for eight characters on
screen at any given time Assassin's
Creed allowed for 120 but after nearly
two years of development Ubisoft was not
ready to give over the project to a new
IP the game had you play as an assassin
bodyguard of The Prince and watch over
him through guided scenario in which
you'd have to use your skills to save
him or get him out of other perilous
situations so basically the entire game
was one big escort mission
hmm thankfully the prince character was
dropped and the Assassin's Creed evolved
into the game we know it as today
[Music]
Assassin's Creed defined what the open
world genre would look like for Ubisoft
during the past three console
Generations the series itself has gone
through some award-winning highs lows
that have made it a divisive series
throughout the gaming industry and a
reinvention that flipped the formula in
a fascinating way it's been enthralling
to go back to 2007 and see where the
series has come from along with the
thought and principle that went into its
world and story with the new entry in
the series Assassin's Creed Mirage
freshly announced an emphasis on a Back
to Basics mentality from Ubisoft will be
interesting to see how they execute it
within the framework of how different
Assassin's Creed looks and feels today
from its inception for more on
Assassin's Creed Mirage make sure you
subscribe to Gamespot check out our
Rockstar editor Jordan remains chat with
the art director of Assassin's Creed
Mirage come find me on Twitter at Stewie
review and thanks for watching
welcome to Skull and Bones our game
takes place during the Golden Age of
piracy and a world inspired by the
beautiful yet dangerous Indian Ocean
you'll start your journey as an outcast
whose goal is to become the most
infamous pirate to sail these
treacherous Waters
foreign
a shipwreck you begin your adventure in
Saint Anne one of the pirate dens in our
world dens are centers of pirate
activity where you can craft new ships
and Equipment provision for your
Expeditions at Sea pick up contracts and
socialize with other players
any pirate with their cell will tell you
that preparation is key to success
get ready for any challenges that come
your way by checking that your cargo is
stocked with items like food and
ammunition
once you're set it's time to head out
and explore
as a rookie pirate you'll only have
access to a small Dow but as you
progress you'll be able to craft
different shifts each with their own
unique play style
at Sea you'll need to pay close
attention to the condition of your ship
and the morale of your crew your crew
are a pack of vicious Raiders and Rovers
who will Mutiny against you if not kept
well fed and happy
if your ship sinks you'll lose some
progress and respawn at the nearest
discover Den or Outpost
the good news is that most of your cargo
will be recovered and you'll have the
opportunity to retrieve the rest from
the wreckage but you'd better be quick
as other players can also steal it
as a pirate Captain your reputation is
everything and our game tracks this
through infamy the higher your infamy
the more opportunities you'll get one of
the many ways to grow your infamy is to
take up contracts these are deals that
you can make with other pirates in the
world contracts can have great rewards
if you're successful or costs if you
fail
you can also gain infamy by completing
other activities such as exploration
plundering treasure hunts investigations
Dynamic events and much more you can
undertake these either Solo or with
other players the world of skull and
bones is filled with riches and
resources that you'll be able to gather
as you explore
lagoons and rivers are teeming with
dangerous wildlife that you can hunt for
animal skins and meet
you'll also be able to harvest a variety
of raw materials such as ore and wood
that can be refined and used for
crafting
crafting is an essential activity for
you to progress as an Infamous pirate
obtain Blueprints and use your refined
resources to craft stronger ships
weapons and armors
in Skull and Bones ships serve many
different purposes cargo ships are
slower but useful if you need to
transport large volumes of loot
navigation ships sail faster but have
less cargo space and lower Hull HP
Firepower ships have more gun ports
allowing you to deal higher damage but
are more challenging to maneuver
similarly you can craft a wide array of
unique weapons and armors from Greek
fires to Giant ballista to rocket
launchers and mortars as well as
different armor types which have varying
strengths and weaknesses against
incoming attacks
with your new Fleet and growing Arsenal
create a Loadout based on your personal
play style to become a force of
disruption
out in the open ocean opportunities and
threats are abundant use your Spyglass
to identify lucrative trade routes or
wealthy Merchant ships and assess your
praised cargo and Firepower
strategize a plan of attack based on
your opponent's defenses and take
advantage of their weak points to deal
more damage
sinking your foes from afar rewards you
with only a portion of their cargo as
some of it will be lost to the deaths
getting in close to execute a boarding
maneuver will help maximize your gains
but beware you can turn from Predator to
prey in a heartbeat if you attract The
Unwanted attention of privateers the
merciless pirate Hunters that Patrol the
seeds
if you enjoy the thrill of the hunt you
can also seek out other players and
Reign Terror on them
such PVP battles are high-stakes
activities that can be rewarding if you
emerge Victorious
from your Spoils of battle personalize
your individual look with outfits that
command respect
[Music]
you can also select from a multitude of
ship customization options to instill
fear in your enemies
With The Wind in your sails Journey to
the furthest reaches of the Indian Ocean
from the coast of Africa to the East
Indies
encounter extreme weather events like
violent storms and monstrous roadways
keep your eyes peeled for outposts which
are safe spots where you'll be able to
dock your ship for a short rest from the
perilous seeds here you can trade with
traveling merchants and clandestine
Smugglers selling rare and illegal Goods
uncover buried bounties at outposts as
you decipher treasure maps obtained
through your voyages although all the
content and skull and bones can be done
solo you might enjoy ruling the Seas
with your friends while sailing you can
also easily invite other Pirates you
encounter to group up synergize your
different play Styles ships and weapons
to defeat deadlier enemies
as you grow stronger take on more
difficult challenges such as attacking
Forts and plundering settlements and if
you're bold enough engage in Dynamic
events like taking down heavily Laden
Merchant ships and their Fleet of
Warship escorts
now it's up to you to write your own
story remember there is no one path to
follow no one way to play the world of
skull and bones is yours to discover
at least that's what I hear
the empire
[Music]
they're everywhere
but the world here
belongs to syndicates
[Music]
I want to survive
I have to play their game
looks like I'm all in
she's in here somewhere
one second thought I'm out
[Music]
there she is
I've been held back my whole life
and now
I just need a chance to finally be free
wherever that takes me
I'm here to offer you a way out okay
get off my ship Jalen give me a chance
you're gonna have to trust me it'll be
dangerous risky but if you pull this off
you'll never look over your shoulder
again
[Music]
foreign
the underworld shows no mercy
but it's a big Galaxy out there and I'm
gonna risk it All
[Music]
Star Wars Outlaws coming 2024.
thank you
[Music]
verse him
are you ready to give up who you once
thought you were I am
[Music]
[Applause]
ready to sacrifice everything your
health clothes I am
[Music]
foreign
I am
let's go
[Music]
then out of the dark you will come into
the light
[Music]
and from the light
you will return to the dark
all right
[Music]
never forget the tenants you have sworn
to uphold
[Music]
stay your blade from the Flesh of the
innocent
[Music]
hide in plain sights
never compromise the Brotherhood
[Music]
thank you
from this day forward
you are a hidden one
[Music]
foreign
Assassin's Creed Mirage coming 2023
[Music]
people and rightly so but what if I told
you in the five years since release it
has become one of the best Ghost Recon
games of all time and an excellent open
world game hello and welcome to Gamespot
no HUD the show where we take a look at
some of your favorite games and tweak
the settings just enough to create a
brand new experience today we're taking
a look at Ghost Recon breakpoint and
we're going to turn this into the
Tactical tense shooter that we all
wanted now this is going to be a tough
Mission so we've recruited deep Ghost
Recon expert to guide us along the way
foreign
[Music]
built upon 2017's Ghost Recon wildlands
as another open world Ghost Recon game
however instead of refining its Co-op
sandbox and the Tactical opportunities
it presented breakpoint buried those
core ideas under a loot-based shooter
with color-coded loot gear scores and
even raids yes they put raids in a ghost
recon game while the moment-to-moment
gameplay was nearly identical to
wildlands the loot grind not only
compromised the identity of Ghost Recon
but also poisoned the entire experience
for many the pitch was a tactical
shooter with survival mechanics some of
which were interesting others of which
felt underdeveloped the delivery however
was an underwhelming Ghost Recon game
that abandoned ITS Tactical roots in
favor of chasing Trends with a poorly
implemented live service model it was a
disaster from top to bottom but this is
a Redemption story
so how do we turn this mess into one of
the best tactical Shooters on the market
we'll take you through the process to
show you how we'll be incorporating
tweaks and new features that ubisoft's
own patches introduced before taking
matters into our own hands with a mod
that is going to rework The Experience
significantly and we'll have deep
explain what the impact of this is I
thankfully Ubisoft did some of the heavy
lifting back in 2020 when it introduced
something called ghost experience
parameters yes it's really called ghost
experience parameters this update
allowed players to hop in the settings
menu and rebalance the entire game in a
matter of seconds more importantly you
can even turn off the terrible gear
score and loot system altogether which
we're gonna do right now I've got
nothing against loot systems I've played
my fair share of Destiny and they can
offer a rewarding Loop but they don't
belong in a ghost recon game what Elite
operative is constantly changing their
clothes and tossing away equipment for
new ones that incrementally make them
feel more powerful none the answer is
none so where do we go from here well
this is where deep comes in he's put in
over 600 hours in break point and he
doesn't just play this game he makes it
sing
thank you
it has to be extreme I have the Tactical
difficulty put up too late and the
interface the whole HUD is pretty much
nothing I don't have Anna hang up except
for the objective that I'm going to just
because if I don't have guided mode on I
will go on the tangent and I will get
lost it's pretty much Bare Bones zero
HUD and just a little bit of guidance
from the game well this show is called
no HUD so I guess it makes sense just to
turn basically everything off like Steve
said the only thing I'm going to leave
on are the objective markers so I don't
get lost or distracted however when
watching Deep's gameplay I did notice
one important HUD element missing
reticles yeah no Crosshair which was a
learning experience but I feel like the
more I play it I'm looking for more and
more of a challenge and to be more
immersed and yeah across hair was
breaking the immersion for me at a
little bit so I got rid of it this may
seem daunting even a bit absurd for a
third person shooter with
over-the-shoulder aiming but breakpoint
provides you with the tools to overcome
this the obvious choice is to turn off
over the shoulder aiming altogether this
means that aiming will default to iron
sights and Scopes if you prefer the
over-the-shoulder style of aiming you
can track down a laser sight that said
if you've never played breakpoint before
I don't recommend turning everything off
right out of the gate now the gameplay
experience will be predominantly defined
by the Tactical difficulty menu here you
can tweak a wide range of settings that
can fundamentally change the game the
biggest example of this is gear score
which we've already turned off while Dee
said he doesn't typically play
breakpoint like a survival game he does
set the Tactical difficulty to Elite at
least as a starting point this means
bandages are limited risk of injury is
set to always stamina consumption is
Extreme health does not regenerate and
ammo is lost on reloads additionally
syringes don't heal injuries if that
wasn't enough darkest night mode is also
turned on meaning visibility is reduced
used at night this hopefully will force
us to use our night vision goggles more
okay let's pause here for just one
second I need to emphasize that we're
not trying to make Ghost Recon
breakpoint as hard as possible instead
we're trying to make it the most tense
tactical shooter it can possibly be of
course for some people the fun is in
making the overall experience more
punishing but for others these settings
promote that thoughtful play style it's
all about finding your sweet spot so
when you fire up breakpoint to revisit
it I suggest you play around with these
parameters and see what fits your play
style some of these settings even lean
more to the survival aspect that gives
more purpose to some of breakpoint's
more extraneous mechanics like drinking
water and cooking
okay
now a key component of every good
tactical shooter is difficulty and enemy
AI enemies should be aggressive
responsive and deadly this forces you to
play smart and think multiple steps
ahead if the AI lacks in any of these
areas the gameplay can devolve into a
super soldier shooting gallery which
isn't the Ghost Recon way the best
tactical Shooters reward careful
planning as much as quick judgment calls
and unfortunately even on break points
harder difficulties you can rip through
enemies and outposts without giving it
much of a second thought there's not a
lot of risk unless you are severely
underprepared thankfully the Ghost Recon
Community has already addressed this
issue with the Spartan mode mod one of
the coolest things it does is it beefs
up the perception of the enemy AI which
I think that a lot of people who have
played on Extreme for long enough will
complain that the AI don't really
respond as much as they should to things
going on around them this mod isn't
technically a new difficulty mode the
Moder who goes by Van andar describes it
as a rebalancing that tweaks enemy
Behavior this mod also makes it
particularly difficult to take down a
base during the daytime which makes
sense since they'll have better
visibility during the day vandar
recommends setting the enemy difficulty
to the second hardest difficulty Advance
rabbit in the hardest Elite given the
ai's improved awareness elite can be
particularly brutal borderlining on
unfair when you load up breakpoint after
making all of these changes it feels
like a very different game and in a
sense it is the minimal HUD forces you
to pay more attention to your
surroundings and listen for nearby
threats the inability to Mark enemies
requires you to keep a mental map of the
area information typically available to
the player is stripped away so that the
Intel Gathering and strategic
considerations that Define the Ghost
Recon experience return to the
foreground it's impossible to know how
many foes are patrolling a point of
Interest unless you do some actual Ghost
Recon even the topography time of day
and weather needs to be considered when
you play This Way mountain ranges can
give you better sight lines to gather
information and pick off stray enemies
if you have the range while valleys
could leave you exposed and in a
precarious position time of day
especially with darkest night mode
enabled as well as weather can also
significantly hinder your visibility
which could be used to your advantage if
you take a stealthy approach or a
detriment if you allow the mission to
devolve into an all-out uncontrolled
firefight
thank you
reconnaissance and careful coordination
pays off in dividends when playing this
way planning and orchestrating a
successful attack based on your own
Intel that you had to uncover yourself
is incredibly satisfying it slows down
the overall pace of the game but it
makes encounters feel more meaningful
throughout that said I do think turning
off the HUD wholesale can be pretty
off-putting especially for those that
may not be familiar with all of ghost
recon's mechanics without pickup markers
you probably won't be able to tell loot
from environmental dressing and without
a detection indicator it can be very
hard to tell where an enemy spots you
from thankfully nearly every little HUD
detail can be customized I suggest
starting with light or minimal interface
presets and then customize from there as
you get more comfortable at the very
least I'd turn off the health bar ammo
counter and minimap the red vignette
makes it pretty obvious when you're low
on health and your character will limp
if they are injured if you leave
objective markers and waypoints on
however you can get by without the
mini-map entirely if you're playing
Co-op though you may want to leave the
compass on with a minimal HUD this makes
coordination more intense as it forces
you and your buddies to accurately call
out cardinal directions rather than
relying on red flips
[Music]
while chatting with diff one thing he
said stuck out to me the ability to be
methodical be tactical just kind of
living out the fantasy of being you know
a special spec opposition I feel like
Ghost Recon lets you explore these
opportunities with your imagination a
bit more it's interesting that we have
that option to express a bit more of our
preferences our our own identity within
breakpoint I think what's most
surprising is that with all these
settings whether intentional or not
Elevate breakpoint Beyond an open world
tactical shooter it almost scratches a
role-playing itch that I never expected
in a game like Ghost Recon sure there's
different classes and skill trees but by
the end I had unintentionally created a
backstory and personality for my
character that informed my play style
it's rare to see this kind of
flexibility when it comes to Modern game
design but in the case of Ghost Recon
breakpoint it recontextualizes the
entire experience and therein lies the
beauty of breakpoint and also the point
of no HUD this show is about finding new
and interesting ways to play games Ghost
Recon breakpoint players were dealt a
bad hand when the game was released but
with the changes we've suggested you can
lay all its cards on the table rearrange
them and play with the deck of your own
creation Ghost Recon breakpoint is more
than just a pretty island with guns it's
a Sandbox brimming with possibility and
honestly the more I think about it I
think it's safe to say that Ghost Recon
breakpoint earns the Tom Clancy Ghost
Recon name
thanks again for checking out this
episode of no HUD if there's games you'd
like to see us cover in the future make
sure to let us know in the comments
below and hey while you're down there
let me know how you play Ghost Recon
breakpoint I'd love to know I'll see you
next time
our kingdom is cursed
the prince has been kidnapped and taken
to a forbidden land
all hope rests with us the Immortals to
rescue him and save the empire
we weren't prepared for what was coming
next
up so I can't say no
then again they weren't prepared for me
now I'm about to turn it down
these times of Darkness hope is the only
thing that keeps us fighting
I will fulfill my destiny and save the
kingdom
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
and welcome to gamespot's pre-show for
Ubisoft forward 2023 I'm Lucy joined by
Michael Hein hey what to do hello
hello my boys are we excited for Ubisoft
forward today yes it's the final day of
our well actually it's my final day of
covering the Azure greater sgf events I
think they can uh they can come out with
a banger they got a I mean after Xbox
yeah the bar is very high but uh but I'm
excited to see what they got because uh
I think they got some they got some good
things cooking yeah
had Avatar frontiers of Pandora writers
Republic Assassin's Creed Valhalla and
Assassin's Creed Mirage obviously since
then we have had a couple more game
announcements from Ubisoft so we had
Prince of Persia the brand new one from
the team behind Rayman Legends as well
as Star Wars Outlaws
uh there is a lot to go through already
we're keeping our pre-show relatively
short because Ubisoft has their own
pre-show that we'll be throwing to in a
few minutes and as well they actually
have an extended post show yeah where
they're going to be showing a bunch more
gameplay which is very exciting so let's
talk quickly about what we're excited
for today Assassin's Creed Mirage uh a
return to the roots of Assassin's Creed
no longer
a giant sprawling
not mess but you know overwhelming
experience I mean I said best depends on
who you ask exactly uh no I I mean I
enjoy the later Assassin's Creed but
that's not why I fell in love with this
yeah absolutely um Michael how are you
feeling about Mirage
I am pretty positive because like I said
I I I love Assassin's Creed Assassin's
Creed 2 still one of my favorite games
but I remember finishing that game in a
smooth 20 to 25 hours I would love
another Assassin's Creed like that uh
but you know I think the formula is
still there and the the bloat that has
kind of plagued I guess uh depending on
who you ask the series is kind of just
it's not necessarily that it's bad it's
just that it becomes intimidating
um so I think that this could encourage
a lot more people to jump back in where
they don't feel like they are committing
to something so huge that they're never
going to finish and like Assassin's
Creed stories can be very exciting and I
would like to see the end of one you
know in a in a brief period of time but
I mean like yeah I still think they they
can Channel some of that energy though
from older Assassin's Creeds yeah Tam
yeah I think this is going to be a good
opportunity for them to I hope that it's
a success uh I hope that it looks good I
think it could create this second branch
of an Assassin's Creed game they
undoubtedly will still want to do those
big open world games because they know
that the data shows that people like it
and it's and it you know they can
continue to plug content in there but
this could be an opportunity for them to
be like hey people like the smaller ones
let's have an offshoot you know and
start working on the kind of
um yearly cycle being a big one small
one big one small one so yeah yeah I
mean if we're talking about broader
Assassin's Creed there are a number of
projects uh in production so rocking
through them so we've got Assassin's
Creed Mirage uh golden age of Baghdad
and then hex which is the Clint Hocking
one 16th century Europe which trial
stuff this has been announced I don't
anticipate it showing up today at all
but there's also Nexus which is the VR
game project red Japan Jade which is the
open world game Set uh the open world
mobile game set in China the Netflix
series and as well there is infinity
which is gonna be then
no so it's basically an online I guess
if you were being reductive you could
call it a launcher but it's basically a
platform for Assassin's Creed but you
can buy the other games separately they
were saying but what you could do is you
could be yeah how's it all in one place
even though they have their view play
because it was used
um yeah that all that all seems though
but I I it's one of those things where I
don't know if uh you know you don't want
one thing to overshadow the other yeah
we want to focus on pushing Mirage
making sure people understand what that
is
um I would love to see uh the other what
else they got because they got
Assassin's Creeds one of their strengths
is just pulling from history whatever
whatever era of History you're
interested in Assassin's discreet is
probably gonna touch it so
um yeah big surprise from Jeff keeley's
show on Thursday was the brand new
Prince of Persia game made by I believe
the Montpellier team the Rayman team uh
looks awesome very I mean obviously this
is hot on the heels of the fact that
pretty special sounds of time which was
being made by the Mumbai team
uh is been rebooted essentially
development has now been taken to
Ubisoft Montreal and uh they've
basically said it's now back in the
conception phase which is wild to think
that it was supposed to launch you know
yeah so it's a shame so if that project
is still cooking I'm still excited to
play it but taking Prince of Persia back
to its real OG roots and then yeah
putting in some I don't know like
Detroit
I mean dead cells feel about it it looks
super cool I'm excited to see more yeah
that studio Montpellier has made some of
the best Platformers in recent memory
like with the rayman's Raymond
um but yeah I've got high hopes for it
they they know what they're doing I feel
like this is a good opportunity for them
to expand a bit and look at how the
genre has evolved and perhaps put that
in one place and even take it a step
further so I'm excited to see more of it
yeah especially from the gameplay that
we saw so like the combat Focus was like
oh it's not just the
um like a like a 2d platformer in a way
so that combat kind of looks sick from
the trailer that we saw at sgf
um and it kind of like hold people over
for the the big Prince of Persia that
everyone was kind of expecting so I I
hope people don't look at this and be
like oh this is just a like a stop gap
for the big Prince of Persia thing wow
this actually looks like something that
is um putting a lot of effort into
because I want to see Ubisoft try
smaller projects I mean like think about
that time you know around 2014 when you
had stuff like chart of light yeah that
was around the time that Rayman was
valuable back and yeah yeah not
everything has to be a huge AAA swing
right so I want to see more of that and
that's what that looks like speaking of
huge AAA swings uh Avatar Frontiers
Pandora they said they're going to be
showing off again today uh
don't ask me about Avatar all right
that's the thing how is Avatar one of
the biggest Entertainment Properties of
all time
I couldn't tell you anything about it
damn the room I only know Jake Sully
yeah Hallelujah Mountain yeah I
Sigourney weave isn't it yeah I mean
like there is potential for that
franchise to exist in a big way in video
games just because the technology that
is used to bring it to life and movies
is not that far removed from the
technology that is used to bring games
to life yeah so I feel like there is a
pipeline of uh people who are into blue
people on big screen into being into
blue people on a smaller screen and
controlling them directly
um it would just be interesting to see
what uh what kind of the format of the
game is
um just because like is it going to be a
traditional Ubisoft Style game or is it
going to be something new that you know
the team is has figured out and are
trying to kind of set for or for the
franchise and maybe Ubisoft is trying to
position himself as a studio that can do
these big licensed properties again
because things are considering they have
the other big property yep which brings
us on to Star Wars Outlaws uh debuted at
the Xbox conference yesterday uh I I'm
not a Star Wars person whoa dude don't
say that no no I say it quite a lot I'm
just I just don't have the interest in
it anymore I mean I enjoyed Jedi
Survivor yeah I thought that was fun
because in a lot of ways it didn't
necessarily feel like it doesn't feel
like
um Star Wars Outlaws then what are we
anticipating this is the next one from
massive uh
yeah it's again it's nice to see massive
try something other than division or
trying to Branch out of that and maybe
Star Wars is the is a good property to
work with because as we've seen like a
lot of the extended Universe stuff is
good Jedi Survivor
um well you don't you don't you don't
um like uh and or you're an Andor hater
yeah I am an Android damn you hate to
see it uh but I do like some of the
smaller stories not everything has to be
about becoming a Jedi and Swinging
lightsabers around uh and the star was
Outlaws from what we saw previously
during sgf's like okay cool maybe use
use that that universe that rich
universe as a platform to tell smaller
stories that can you know send different
messages build out the world a little
bit more and you know as you slap the
Star Wars name on it people go and buy
it yeah because too big to fail yeah
the thing with Avatar too is like I
didn't think people were gonna like
really rock with an Avatar movie and
they came out this year right so late
last year they came out droves though
you know what I'm saying so uh maybe
Ubisoft is printing money out there with
these two properties that they got
we've also we know there's going to be X
to find there
um the thing that I want to talk about
is things that we know Ubisoft has
cooking that we might
maybe see today
you know stuff like I think work I
assume
bones babies skull and bones
are showing up today
um
rather do you think they're gonna be
like what are you talking about
[Music]
I genuinely think there would be some
kind of and of course we're working
we're still continuing development on
skull and bones but then move on and
then just move on I don't know if I can
say with any confidence that we'd
actually even see it today because who
even knows what
time with that game it was meant to come
out last year this time last year was
this supposed to come out in 2018 or
some [__] oh yeah oh my God hey show us
show us the skulls and show us the bones
yeah let's get this thing popping come
on now yeah uh Splinter Cell as well
if they do
I've I'm my I maintain my position on
that like that it's it Ubisoft
disrespecting so in a way that I haven't
seen franchise has been disrespected
since the legacy of Kane
or metal gear uh but yeah they keep
doing the thing where they're like we're
making this and then not showing us or
like just
letting it kind of linger in the air I
reached a point now where if I think
about it so it just makes me angry so
like and they talk about they have I
would love to see just a clip a small
something hey hey look here's our our
modern model for Sam Fisher sure like
this is what it's going to look like
just give us a scene from the remake or
whatever
I'll take it but I'm I don't have any
expectations that will show up I'd be
like to be surprised but I don't I don't
think they're gonna yeah I think they're
going to be like Assassin's Creed
Assassin's Creed Assassin's Creed
Assassin's Creed Assassin's Creed Star
Wars extra five extra fine you want Sam
Fisher play X to fight they'll put
they'll put Sam Fisher in Prince of
Persia hell yeah that's what they did
before they'll put him in his own game
oh man bring back my favorite favorite
fed in it I don't mess with the feds but
Sam Fisher that's my guy a cab accept
time wow that's on record boy come on
now
uh Michael you expecting to see um
he's right though he will show up likely
show up in next to find more yeah oh
yeah or the third echelon is in extra
fine yeah you should check out Jacob
Decker's preview of xdefine on
gamespot.com if you want to know more
about that but
um yeah Third Echelon is in the game so
it's like
Sam Fisher's minions yeah uh in terms of
other big Ubisoft properties of course
Far Cry it's been a couple years since
Far Cry six
uh which didn't really I don't know
again it kind of has succumbed to the
Assassin's Creed curse a little bit but
very it's overly big due for a comeback
though given the the lice the kind of
brand is still kind of expanding right
they have that Netflix show is that a
thing is it is it a Netflix Far Cry show
what's the Ubisoft show that they're
doing on Netflix Assassin's Creed oh God
actually I've been telling you they keep
trying to do the same thing over and
over again yeah I'm not yeah I'm not
anticipating any far cry today but it'll
be good to get a little check in on our
friends maybe it may be a teaser you
know maybe they'd be like 20 24 origin
Far Cry 2 remake oh okay I'll be down
for that we figured it out with um Watch
Dogs we're gonna put that stuff back in
the original game clean this is like I'm
back baby yeah I know but like he's got
other stuff cooking yeah uh and just for
my own oh I see what she has yeah I see
what she got Just Dance
Just Dance will be there for sure like
there will be dances at some point
um Beyond Good and Evil
good luck with that yeah
I mean
and I I have said this every year since
Maybe
routine
just no it doesn't exist anymore just
tell us it's gone the announcement Hotel
just tell us is gone even when they
announced it I remember thinking like
this ain't gonna exist did you even play
the first game I went to a preview for
it you saw it I saw it and they also
spent a copious amount of time just
showing us artwork on a wall and being
like this is this this is going to be
this and it's gonna be this and they
showed us a bit of the game and then
they were like all right we'll see you
very soon for an update very soon all
right we are gonna throw over to Ubisoft
fingers and toes crossed for Beyond Good
evil two uh we're gonna be also talking
over the Showcase over on Giant Bomb if
you want to check that out thank you for
joining us enjoy going
and convince people that the site that
they were supposed to be attacking on
wasn't actually there because you had
you know successfully hidden the bond
most hero Shooters dream
of having their entire roster
essentially be viable operators and I
think Siege has really nailed that when
I stream Rainbow Six
one who hasn't
hasn't been playing Emerald planes and
they're like what is that map like who
are you even playing we're about to get
the rework the consulate which I think
is huge playing around on reworked maps
and doing things like replay C4s and
pull scanning from boil
those tactical plays are some of the
most satisfying that you ever get in
gaming cross progression was awesome I
you know I started on PS4 so I had
several years from being one of those
veteran year one players under my belt
and so I had all the cool skins and even
levels renowned all that all that kind
of stuff so having that suddenly be on
my PC account which I started I don't
know probably three years uh into my
journey was fantastic console Community
has been begging Ubisoft for some kind
of answer to the like Zim situation and
I know The Mousetrap was a huge huge
announcement that a lot of console
players were waiting for the most
groundbreaking thing added to siege for
me was ranked 2.0 I'm really excited for
the changes uh for the shields I feel
like it's been a long time coming I love
things like the shooting range being
able to change attachments um switch
seamlessly between weapons and operators
it's an amazing change
the newest season has just been released
and a whole lot more is on the way so
there's a lot of Siege to be excited for
why not go watch a game in action and
see for yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
when you experience the adrenaline to
playing tournaments to win tournaments
[Music]
you know that you can't live without
that anymore
if you like moving countries to pursue
my dream and career it was very
difficult at the beginning because I had
to left some people behind you know
Brazil but you have to be the best you
have to think that you are the best
there's a pressure like of being a team
captain because uh like for example if
I'm not scared to play a match like my
team's not gonna be scared you know like
on social media when people see that
they they respect me everybody's gonna
look up to us like oh a new Dynasty you
know like the The Forbidden word I feel
we have everything we need to be the
best team in the world we just have to
prove to everyone else my dream is to
win like two two big tournaments in a
row
to win this most important thing
if we lose this game I win this game
like it's my fault you know
so it's all on my shoulders
[Music]
we work in a discipline that has certain
gaps between the people that make
buildings and the people that use
buildings and I think we could use games
and virtual spaces as a way of breaking
down those boundaries and inviting new
audiences to participate in
architectural design there's an
important relationship between
architecture urbanism and video games an
understanding of how real cities are
forming how people behaved in cities how
people gathered in crowds is often very
very helpful in being able to articulate
that meaningfully in a fictional world
as well
[Music]
video game urbanism is the name of our
teaching Studio we've been teaching this
for a number of years now working with
students to promote the use of game
engine technology as an architectural
method for design we've been Gamers
since we were young and I think that
really informed in some way our decision
to become Architects because we've
always been really interested by spaces
so Ubisoft approached us to reinterpret
one of their games in any way we'd like
to we were interested in how Unity opens
up the city in a new way rather than
buildings the rooftops the facade
interacting with architecture in a
different way as Architects we're
trained to see buildings in a particular
way but a game like Assassin's Creed
Unity lets us break that and see the
city in a new light
so when we were researching the game we
found it really interesting to read some
of the interviews and some of the
material from the developers as to how
they approached the design of the
architecture and hearing that you know
you're facing real virtual problems we
also face as Architects sometimes was a
really interesting Insight we thought it
would be really interesting to explore
video game architecture using an
architectural methodology such as a
scaled model so we go from the Riverside
to the old kind of medieval areas of the
city where the buildings are much
smaller and irregular through to the
larger kind of Buddha boards and we're
standing here in the both of Commerce
which is obviously the highlight of the
model here
we picked the aloe blade because we
think it was a really good example of a
building that's use has changed maybe
quite a lot from the game to the present
day even to the fact that it's got a new
insertion in it from an architect that
we really loved and it was a really
interesting building to look at
we really like the way that games are
totally kind of user-centric spaces
which is definitely something
architecture can learn from
foreign
[Music]
oh my face
right
stay tuned for exclusive reviews on
Avatar frontiers of Pandora Assassin's
Creed Mirage and the crew motorfest all
in 10 minutes
foreign
[Music]
it's okay to be scared I know
yes
[Music]
I'm still learning about mentality if
you got to work on yourself you got to
be better about it
[Music]
Christine got blues Christine got blues
she ain't got it
unless it's a blue eight and then we'll
be screwed so all right
oh [__]
[Music]
oh my God
[Laughter]
oh oh
man I mean we kind of caught the
transition we did another casserole bar
spin there
fore eliminated I knew I'd been training
for the splits for a reason oh my God
I'm so excited it's coming tomorrow it's
coming tomorrow I'm amazed I'm so
excited I'm so excited
oh
did he crash into me
Layla your dance was so amazing by the
way I want you to know that Ubisoft San
Francisco just only ten thousand dollars
I know I know right
what in the [__]
what is happening this thing looks like
the wide body of the future what the
heck is this I don't even know what to
say it's like bottoming out I saw you
drive the thing
oh right that's a thing I remember
really we did
oh my God
that's crazy wow that's uh we started at
like 13 000 something so yeah getting to
the 15 is insane
[Music]
thanks everyone
the show's about to begin get your
snacks get settled ready let's go
[Music]
foreign
but you miss me
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
jump on the Dance Floor
[Music]
three years
music is nice
[Music]
[Applause]
shake it
shake it shake
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the rda's breed poisoned our world
press must be eliminated
they took everything from us
me
I was trained in their ways their
technology
their weapons
things that a nappy should not know
and then one day
they left Hell's Gate is under attack
evacuate Now kill all the navi children
but before they did our teacher saved us
and put us to sleep
this is your only chance to survive
and there I remain for 15 years
until one day
I awoke
I was free
free to explore my world
free to decide who I was going to be
ever what I was meant to do
[Music]
foreign
don't let the Navi get in our way get
rid of them and I have a choice to make
I choose to protect my home
I was a child of Two Worlds
I am no longer
[Music]
I am not me
evaco
hi there everyone I'm Jim Cameron the
creator of Avatar and Avatar the way of
water
in developing both of these films I set
out to imagine another world a world is
Rich and complex as our own
and we wanted the audience to feel as
though they were really on Pandora to
dream with their eyes wide open and to
explore this world with our characters
and it's always been our vision to
embrace technology to allow us to find
new ways outside the cinema to immerse
people in this world
our friends at Ubisoft share the same
ambition and the team at massive have
been pushing the boundaries of what's
possible in games to bring a new corner
of Pandora to life
so with Avatar frontiers of Pandora our
creative team at lightstorm has been
able to share their insights with
massive talented team who are experts in
creating living open worlds
together we'll be able to bring players
to the Western frontier with new
environments new flora and fauna new
characters and an original story that
coexists with the events of the Avatar
films
we can't wait for you to join this
adventure and we look forward to
welcoming you back to the world of
Avatar once again
we can't wait for you to join this
adventure and we look forward to
welcoming you back to the world of
Avatar once again
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone
my name is Tita deenfeld and ask the
game director I'm proud to be
representing the team behind Avatar
frontiers of Pandora today and excited
to share a sneak peek of what we've been
working on
in this all new story you'll set out on
a journey of Discovery to unravel the
mysteries of your past learn what it
means to be Navi and explore new parts
of Pandora on land or together with your
trusted Banshee in the air
our ambition is to create a playground
where curiosity is rewarded this
tangible and highly immersive
first-person experience will allow you
to closely connect to a beautiful open
world touch and interact with it using
your size your superhuman strength and
your natural agility to gain the upper
hand
let's rise to the challenge on December
7th
until then
we're delighted to show you a glimpse of
this adventure so prepare to lose
yourselves in the Beauty and the danger
of the Western frontier
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to Avatar frontiers of Pandora
the first person action adventure game
that invites you to explore the engaging
world of Avatar in an immersive open
World Experience I'm Didi deanfeld game
director and I'm excited to reveal
what's waiting for you on Pandora
story of our game begins when the RDA
expands their operations to the Western
frontier
John Mercer one of the leaders of the
RDA abducts you and other Navy children
from your home to teach you the ways of
humans hoping to mold you and Turn you
against your own people
but his plan is interrupted by the
battle of the Hallelujah mountains and
you are put into emergency cryosleep
when you awaken 15 years later you are a
stranger in your birthplace knowing the
dangers posed by the RDA you set out to
take them down and look to secure the
help of other Navi Clans
initially you're perceived as an
outsider so you have to reconnect with
your lost Navi Heritage to gain their
trust
on your adventure you'll find your own
path as you discover what it means to be
naughty you'll explore new regions of
Pandora each with their own unique
biomes
the king Law Forest is a lush rainforest
brimming with life and dense vegetation
in the shade of awe-inspiring floating
mountains
this is the home of the iranahe a clan
of peaceful Weavers who will guide you
on your first hunt and on your first
flight
will show you the way to The Rookery
where you can bond for life with your
very own ecrom
the ikram is a devoted companion that
you can name feed and customize
experiment with acrobatics and feel a
rush of adrenaline as you dive from the
sky and explore the open world of
Pandora from the air if you travel North
you'll get to the upper Plains
an expansive grassland filled with
contrasts and open views as far as the
eye can see
the nomadic sesquite Clan live here in
symbiosis with gigantic beasts called
sakuru
earn the Clan's trust and they will
teach you the art of riding dire horses
further west the mysterious clouded
Forest
were hidden in the Mist nothing is as it
seems
here is the cafeteria a clan of healers
with their own dark reasons to stay
hidden
RDA operations are threatening the
balance of Pandora
they build facilities of all Sciences to
exploit resources at any cost spreading
devastating pollution
in the process animals are hurt and
poached
you'll need to stop the RDA from
ravaging your home and when you are
ready you will take the fight to them
as a child of Two Worlds you can learn
to master multiple combat Styles your
powerful instincts allow you to get an
overview of the battlefield Mark your
enemies and identify weak points
traditional Navi weapons are versatile
and precise you can use the Longbow to
hit long-range targets or the staff's
link to set up traps
for a more explosive approach you can
leverage your human training and go for
the blast of an assault rifle a shotgun
or go bigger with the occasional rocket
launcher
foot you can also rely on your
Incredible strength to take down amp
units above the clouds your ikron will
help you in aerial combat against the
RDA
destroying RDA facilities will have a
tangible impact on your world
with the pollution removed
Pandora heals
you'll be able to harvest the best
quality material again
craft better gear and weapons
you will also find ingredients to cook
and make meals to get stronger
as you keep discovering what it truly
means to become Navi you'll improve your
skills by connecting to Ay through the
tarshu plant and learn from the memories
of your ancestors skill upgrades can
improve many aspects of your character
such as your natural agility to move
through the world your stealth approach
when hunting or fighting or the handling
of your weapons and mounts
Avatar frontiers of Pandora is a
captivating action-adventure game
designed to maximize the power of new
gen consoles and PC
you will be able to play the full story
campaign in single player
or with a friend online in two-player
Co-op
we invite you to explore this world of
wonder
become Navi
take down the RDA to protect Pandora
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone hello hello my name is
Mark Rubin executive producer on X
defiant uh what you just saw was a
collection of live clips and reactions
from players streaming our game during
our closed beta test in April uh and
we've been absolutely overwhelmed by the
amazing response to our game from
players all over the world
now for us Community has really been the
core of this game's development and
we've had 28 public tests so far with
the recent closed beta being the largest
and of course the first with no NDA
and throughout all of these tests we've
done our best to listen and respond to
the feedback of players
so thank you so much to the more than
one and a half million players who have
participated in those tests and the
countless creators and streamers who
shared their footage and feedback about
X defiant
now we're ready to look towards the
future
we are currently planning on launching
later this summer
but before we do that we will be holding
another test to address some of the
feedback from the closed beta this Open
Session will be available to everyone on
PC PS5 and Xbox series X and S from June
21st to June 23rd
this is a short test
but we are opening it to everyone to get
as much feedback as possible on our new
net code our controller tuning and of
course to stress out the servers as much
as possible
so if you have not played X Define it
yet this is your chance
but let's talk about what's going to
happen when we launch later this summer
we will start with a six-week pre-season
that will have all of our launch content
with 14 Maps five factions 24 weapons
and much much more
we then move into our year One content
schedule which is packed with some
really exciting content with four brand
new meta changing factions each with
unique characters and skills 12 new
weapons and 12 new maps
that's one new map every month all
inspired by ubisoft's amazing worlds I
think you may really be surprised at
where we go
year one is really going to have a lot
of great gameplay content all focused on
creating a Fun Arcade FPS experience and
we are committed to staying true to our
community and to strive to make X
defiant the best place to compete and
have fun
now it's been quite the journey to get
to this point so thank you again to all
of the players that supported X Defiance
so far
and for everyone who hasn't yet had the
chance we hope to see you in game soon
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hi everyone it's so exciting to be with
you today
about 30 years ago in 1989
I discovered a great action adventure
game both challenging my skills and
respecting my cleverness
it was Prince of Persia
game director of Prince of Persia the
Lost crown
time has come to open a new chapter and
to journey in legendary Persia in an era
by the laws of Mortals were ruled by The
Laws of Gods
the youngest member of a squad of seven
Elite Warriors The Immortals
one night Prince Hassan sawhead with
Throne is abducted and taken to her
hostile and cursed land mankath
you and your brothers announced are sent
on a risk mission to save Prince Hassan
however this assignment will cast you
straight into the lion's den
and it is here but you Sagan and the
whole Kingdom must prepare to face the
greatest threat of your lies
this is your story in Mount calf your
destiny awaits
foreign
habitants
now separated from your allies we
discover a grand Citadel full of
mysteries when time flows differently
what is this sorcery the past coexists
with the future
in discussed land exploration is
everything
this is semi-open world that delivers
new Secrets as you find new power
but to reach new areas you have to
master your skills and your sense of
timing
the trademark of Prince of Persia
[Music]
during this Epic Journey you won't be
the only one trapped in Mount calf
contest and blacksmith to the Gods
some dwellers are willing to help you
While others are more reluctant
[Music]
the star gun is a short man like no
other
[Music]
and extremely secure on the battlefield
he constantly puts his life on the line
but from the steering attacks
time powers are back
but this time
what the hell was that not only in your
hands
[Applause]
face such a challenge Master on your
side of this time for us
identify gravity
by combining all these kids together you
can express your creativity
to solve montcast Mysteries
and execute brutal combos in Epic
combats
[Music]
thank you
and
that's just
a glimpse of what Prince of Persia the
Lost Crown is all about
I'd like to thank men tricks who
composed the in-game music you are just
listening to and of course my fantastic
team at Ubisoft Montpellier
we cannot wait for you to get your hands
on the game it releases on January 18
2024 on all platform
thank you and enjoy the rest of the show
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
my name is Addie Shankar I'm a TV and
movie producer you may know me from the
Castlevania animated series on Netflix
or one of my fan fiction shorts on
YouTube
seven years ago I got a call from
Ubisoft offering me the opportunity to
adapt one of their uh very very very
serious franchises into an anime
but instead I came back to them with a
crazy concept inspired by the the mood
of Far Cry 3 blood Dragon
yeah
this concept used ubisoft's vast library
of characters and remixed them into one
Delirious anime series
that would become This Love Letter to
the 90s
or at least how I remember the 90s
and to my absolute surprise Ubisoft said
no
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just kidding they said yes
that's why I'm up here
come on
this
anime series by Ubisoft was born
Captain laser Hawk
a blood dragon remix
this show is many things
it's violent
it's a dystopian fiction in the spirit
of the works of all this Huxley it's a
spoof it's a satire
it's dark comedy
it's a love story
and as a descendant of Indian Mystics
I can tell you it's the most
philosophically conscious
show
you've watched in a long time
series was picked up by Netflix
it was animated by the Renegade genius
Pirates at Bobby pills Studio
and today
I'm very happy to announce that barring
an apocalypse
which may happen
it will be released worldwide later this
year
and that's not all
I'm even more excited to share with you
an action-packed Easter egg filled
teaser trailer right now
[Applause]
[Music]
don't change
yeah
foreign
let's do this
[Music]
are you hoping for America
hey everyone
it's an honor for us to be here with you
today we're home free and this is our
song skull and bones
[Music]
this is forever
to
do not put skull in Bones
[Music]
from Outcast a kingdom was born upon the
Sea Bear was meant to walk the land of
pirates life for me I'll ask you winding
up the sails won't speak to Mutiny I'll
find yourself a wanted
[Music]
shores of Saint and to the Eastern
Shores I'll take my chances on the
windows and Thunder scores flag it
stands for us alone no one else around
you are on a Tennessee
[Music]
oh in the heart is
left around
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
get ready
foreign
all right
turn it up I never been a quitter
forget what you do I'm gonna run it up
to the day that I did
too fast
to the metal
s
[Music]
oh yeah
[Applause]
thank you thank you
thank you guys thank you everyone
five years ago recruit you took off now
each month
millions of real Seekers
just like you
are enjoying playing eager to see what's
next
I am stefanberry creative director of
the crew
thanks hey
[Applause]
today at last it is my pleasure to
introduce the future of the crew murder
first
our own new take on the action driving
gendra a celebration for car lovers to
share an experience conquered to your
fantasy on the beautiful island of a wow
in a way
no matter how you enjoy Golf and driving
on your own or weave your crew murder
first has something for everyone
more fast your bottle to medley of
i-octane experiences you choose how you
like to have fun with your cars this is
what more of his playlists are all about
playlists are truly at the heart of
horror first
when I immerse yourself in the most
exciting words of kakuchi
dive
into a legacy of the world's most
influential automakers
light up the night street racing scene
Japanese style
unleash The Cutting Edge power of
electric
Super Girls
and this is just a taste
for the first time ever we'll leave the
U.S Mainland behind our Festival has
landed in one of the most breathtaking
and vibrant places on Earth
Oahu let's find out why Oahu is the
perfect playground
for driving fell
race through the city street of Honolulu
powered up
black hash covered slopes
Adventure deep into Lush rainforests
our Cruiser Jews at Sunset with your
friends
opportunities for fun and challenges are
endless
a unique playground like this course for
profusion of vehicles
choose and customize your ride who is
one of the most diverse lineups ever
from past
presents and Future
recognize the latest from Lamborghini I
think so yeah I know you are as real as
I am to get behind the wheel of this
beauty
hey some of you I spend a lot of energy
building the perfect Bakery collection
in Virtual 2. in a few weeks you will be
able to import your vehicle connection
into the crew model fast for free
thanks
so stay tuned for more news about the
correction Imports and our complete
Festival program later this month during
our summer showcase
since the beginning of the year
thousands of players have tested the
game and giving us Priceless feedback
Through The Insider program
join the party register now for close
beta and share with the world your
experience
in July
from the entire team at Ubisoft avoid
over
Mahalo thank you welcome to Modern Fest
enjoy the ride
thank you
foreign
laughs
thank you
[Music]
hi everyone
I hope you enjoyed that first look at
this exciting new way to play Assassin's
Creed
coming to meta Quest this holiday
Assassin's Creed Nexus will push the
boundaries of VR and let you become the
Assassin
you will feel what it means to parkour
fight and be stealthy in new memories
from three legendary assassins Ezio
Cassandra and Conor
I cannot wait to see our players feel
the thrill of virtual reality in the
Assassin's Creed universe
but there is more Nexus is not the only
game that will offer new ways to play
Assassin's Creed
Assassin's Creed code name Jade is our
first open world RPG game on mobile
it will take you to ancient China in a
time of intrigue and conspiracy
in this brand new adventure you'll
experience the iconic Assassin's Creed
gameplay for free anywhere anytime
I am glad to announce that you can
register now for the upcoming beta
here's a glimpse of what you can expect
[Applause]
[Music]
Legacy
it's honoring those that came before us
learning from their triumphs
and mistakes
to illuminate and hold their stories to
the light for all to see
that inheritance of knowledge helps to
guide and shape our future
now it's your time
to build on those foundations
and rise to even greater Heights
to step out of the shadows and into a
vast world
to make your own legacy
[Music]
[Applause]
we've all been waiting for this moment
Assassin's Creed Mirage is a very
special game
designed as an homage to the first
titles of the series that many of us
fell in love with
coming October 12th Assassin's Creed
Mirage take the franchise back to its
foots
Sarah or narrative director for the game
will come on stage to tell you more
about Bassin and his journey
but before that let's watch our story
trailer
[Applause]
foreign
all right
what does it mean to be free
what must be sacrificed in the Quest for
freedom and Justice the hidden ones
fiercely pursue
how can you find your path and fulfill
your destiny when you don't know who you
really are
as he grows from Street Thief to master
assassin Basim thinks he has found a
sense of purpose as a hidden one working
in the dark to serve the light
but his nightmarish Visions keep
haunting him leading to more questions
with no answer
in Baghdad seeking the truth comes with
a prize
the capital of the Abbasid Empire one of
the richest most diverse and most
advanced cities in the world is at a
turning point of its history
unrest is growing sitting a revolution
against corruption and arbitrary Justice
and the pricing that will turn the tides
of history and change the lives of
everyone
childhood friends fellow hidden ones as
well as newly formed lies and enemies
will shape basim's Adventure but his
horrific Visions are the face of a
struggle that he can only handle alone
there is a lot to look forward to In
Assassin's Creed Mirage and the best way
to make you understand our eunuch back
to the roots experience is to show you
the game
in the following gameplay walkthrough we
meet past him right after the
assassination of his first main target
as he reports back to Roshan in Hobby as
assassin's Bureau enjoy
thank you
[Music]
there you are
not let him Escape
time to vanish
get back here dog
it's time to fight you worm
s
running away
[Music]
thank you
alhamdulillah
I am glad you are safe
[Music]
alhamdulillah a first of many
achievements to come pass him we should
only hope
there's still much work to do
[Music]
while our Focus was on our rule
full of quietly scouted the city for
where we could erect more bureaus I have
found dwellings in three districts that
are most unassuming the bid and Rebecca
have arrived from alamut and set off to
al-abasiya and garch
I will make my way to sharkia shortly
and I will join Rebecca in car
where corruption is as common as the
Arid air
[Music]
about some things he's been working on
then come find us
have a look Blossom I may have something
that is of interest to you
[Music]
resourceful as always
my thanks abujafar
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
let us reconsider the approach
me said she and Ali's followers are
trying to overthrow the prince what
Madness they will surely fail
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hey
the sky is safe my friend
survey the area in kidu
there is my target
you learn your play
oh
[Music]
yes what I wish to know and no more need
die this day
thank you
[Music]
come on
idiot stop it
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone
so first I want to start by saying thank
you to all Gamers all around the world
it signs to you that we are here today
you are at the art of everything we do
and to all Ubisoft teams
around the world as well
I would like to say a big thank you
your talent and passion are at the
foundation
of this fantastic lineup
so I hope you are all excited
to explore the amazing playgrounds you
have seen today
software creators of worlds we are also
proud to partner with some of the
biggest names in entertainment to create
Original Stories in Beloved universes
now I am very happy to welcome Julian
from Ubisoft massive
to give you a first look at Star Wars
Outlook and
and gameplay so thank you
Julian
[Music]
cut calm down do you want to see
gameplay or not
all right let's get over the speech and
let's get to the gameplay
Star Wars Outlaws takes place in a time
of great civil unrest
across the Galaxy
for some
this is a time of turmoil
for outlaws
this is a time of opportunity
as a cunning Thief
and her companion Nix fight for survival
every single day relying on their skills
and resourcefulness to get by
as they struggle to make ends meet
Kay and Nix
dream of the day that they will finally
be free
but while seeking this freedom
K unexpectedly becomes one of the
Galaxy's Most Wanted
so to free herself
from the Bounty that follows her
Kay will need to pull off one of the
greatest heists the outer rim has ever
seen
as they navigate the underworld core
between criminal syndicates and vicious
ruthless villains Kay and Nix will
manage their reputation by taking on
risky contracts and navigating complex
relationships
all whilst avoiding oppressive Imperial
rule
Ken nix's Journey will take them across
the Galaxy through stunning varied open
World locations and the Wilds of space
one of these locations
is Tashara
a moon that features Windswept Savannah
and amberine canyons
carved into tashara's striking landscape
the city of miragana serves as a central
hive
of scum and villainy
KNX will encounter several criminal
syndicates
that learned that everything
is measured in the value of influence
reputation
or cold hard credits
this presents an abundance of
opportunities and dangers
for a young ambitious scoundrel-like k
on behalf of massive in Sweden
along with Ubisoft ANSI Barcelona
Bucharest Chengdu Milan Montpellier
Paris Shanghai Toronto
and our amazing
team at lucasfilm games it's our
privilege
to present to you this first ever look
at Star Wars Outlaws gameplay
if you're willing to take the risk
the Galaxy is full of opportunity thank
you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I want that fighter stripped for parts
by tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
come on
[Music]
foreign
answer
me
thanks
this morning
[Music]
thank you
we need to leave
[Music]
[Applause]
Christmas
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm ready
hi my name is Amberly Gonzalez and I
play k-ves in Star Wars Outlaws
caves is a thief she's a scoundrel she's
really good at sneaking around you know
she's charming and she'll like talk to
you but she's already taking all your
things she isn't perfect at it but she
always seems to get away with it
Kay really finds herself in a bit of a
jam you know she's got a bounty on her
back and is trying to find work that's
when she starts to really realize I kind
of like this underworld business I kind
of like this world and she's trying to
thrive on it she has to survive because
nobody else will save her unless it's
her the only person that she has is her
companion NYX they're not even human but
that is the closest thing she has to
feeling a part of something in the world
I also think that Nyx in a lot of ways
it's kind of an extension of Kate both
in a gameplay sense or a story sense you
know and gameplay allows Kay to do
things she never thought possible and in
the story it's also a way for K to kind
of incense when something's off or or
see an opportunity or that kind of thing
really they're completely connected I
love that relationship I'm so excited
for people to meet next because they're
going to fall in love with him too
[Music]
place right between The Empire Strikes
Back and Return of the Jedi so it's the
civil war between the rebellion and the
Empire that has actually created this
pocket of opportunity for syndicates and
criminal organizations to rise up in
that space we've got the Pikes we've got
the Huts we've got a new Syndicate that
we've crafted for this game called the
ashiga plan and one of the phrases we
always held on to was this notion of you
live and die by your reputation so it's
really exciting 4K and I and hopefully
for players she's so Fearless you'll see
her just go for it and there's no
stopping her even when there's danger
involved even when there's fear
underneath it she'll never let you see
it not really for a scoundrel story you
know you really have to ask yourself
when is enough enough how far is K
willing to go to land that big score and
those are questions he's going to tackle
through the whole story we worked with
lucasfilm every step of the way in
crafting the story and they were an
invaluable partner in helping us Create
and Craft this thing they were really
embracing us with open arms in terms of
hey we want to focus on the underworld
we want to focus on an outlaw navigating
through that space But we're sort of
there to help guide and point out like
hey here's an opportunity you might not
have looked at or there's a character
you might might want to consider so
really it was a partnership through and
through
I feel like this is one of the biggest
if not the biggest franchise of our
lifetime the themes like everything has
just been a part of our world and for me
and and for the world of Star Wars I
know that people are going to love this
game not just for how amazing the
gameplay is but like the story itself to
see a young girl become a woman and
become an outlaw what are you worried no
humberly's energy her humor her wit all
of that really has kind of helped them
form the character she has a way of
jumping between that matinee action high
stakes the tone to shifting to really
intimate really personal performances
that make you connect to Kate getting to
bring my own heart and then mix it in
with that confidence and her toughness
and her charm and wit it's it's really
fun it makes her very endearing even
though she's a very tough person
you won't make a doctor shower alive
Maybe
and yeah it kind of feels like she was
always meant to be okay she informs it
in every way
I love bringing a character like this to
life and it's an honor honestly to be a
part of this world it's definitely a
dream come true and I'm still doing it
so literally like about to hop and do a
scene right now so it's all just
exciting and I feel now I'm really
locked into the character the team is
amazing and I feel very supported and
I'm happy that they found me because I
feel like I was meant to play this role
make sure to catch me alongside with
some developers and cast members at
Comic-Con International this July in San
Diego
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Star Wars
Outlaws official gameplay walkthrough
breakdown I'm Chasity vicencio with
Ubisoft news and I'm joined by narrative
director nabib khabari creative director
Julian Garrity and game director
Matthias Carlson who are going to give
us more information about what we saw in
the gameplay walkthrough
here we go
this is our first ever introduction to
Nyx NYX is a Merkel a rare and exotic
creature whose home planet Still Remains
a mystery he's got a very curious
personality as you can see here he can
be a bit stubborn but he has an
incredibly strong bond with K and always
follows her lead she's grown up with the
Knicks for most of her life he's not
just a pet he's family
[Music]
and here we have okay first introduction
to a brand new scoundrel in this galaxy
K is a young Thief who's found herself
on the moon of Tashara which is a hive
of Underworld activity
picked up a high-risk job to steal a
Priceless sort of mollusk-like object
from a lieutenant of the pike Syndicate
once she's grabbed it with the help of
Nick she's going to turn it in and earn
some much needed credits
so Pikes are one of the syndicates that
we'll be tangling with in uh Star Wars
Outlaws and the Pikes here are borrowing
without permission some vehicles from
the Empire and the rebels and different
people I'm cutting them up next
foreign
just a lovable and fierce companion uh
next is a whole bag of tricks in and of
himself you saw him push that button
from a distance he can distract guards
he can attack on command he can help you
with puzzles he can help you discover
Secrets as well he is very much
conceived as a symbiotic part of the
player's control over Kate and Nick so
we're really thinking of them together
as a whole
I was just leaving
so when we meet K in the beginning again
she knows her way around the Blaster
it's not necessarily her first option or
primary tool to solve a solid problem or
a situation however as we progress
through the game and it's many every
more dangerous situation both K and the
Blaster itself will evolve and improve
and you will soon find it to be a
central and very versatile tool
for more than just directly taking out
then okay okay we'll figure this out
case Blaster is very meaningful to her
and this Blaster has a lot of modules
that you can discover upgrade and apply
to the Blaster that allow you to deal
with situations in radically different
ways
so here I think we have a very good
example of the type of role Knicks can
play even in something like a bull on
fire fight where that enemy that we took
out dropped the gun that he was just
about to shoot you with Knicks can you
know slink down and retrieve that weapon
for you
sometimes best solution is just to get
out of there
so ever since we kicked off this project
in collaboration with lucasfilm games
one of the things that they were
passionate about of course is your
authenticity one of the things we were
passionate about is bringing something
to the Galaxy of Star Wars
and one of the biggest things was this
uh Moon tusharra and Tashara we
developed uh working very closely with
lucasfilm everything from its vegetation
to the wildlife to its deep rich culture
and all of the activities that we can
discover during this trailer and even
more
one of the key pillars for both K the
character and for the the core gameplay
in general and it's always Atlas is what
we call a resourceful Underdog K is a
capable and daring person and we reflect
that in gameplay we do having access to
a wide range of actions and abilities
ever growing of course as you play for
the game ranging from stealth to fall on
fire fights let's be still sore here uh
you know shooting from you know driving
your speed room Full Speed Ahead under a
fire from enemies we said if we can make
the player think like oh I can't believe
I made it when when they just play
through something it's a success
Kay's reputation with the syndicates
will play a big role in how she
approaches her journey whether it's the
Pikes Huts or others we had a saying
that in the Underworld you live and die
by your reputation as if a job she takes
hurts a Syndicate those opportunities
aren't available so our choices play
into how she experiences
John's Hope
Johnson's hope is one of the settlements
that we have in the game so this is a
tiny outcrop an oasis of civilization in
these Windswept planes and it usually
contains a drinking hole Cantina and
these are hubs of activity too so we
very much enjoyed developing how it
would look and feel and what sort of
vibe that Cantina would have
but this is just one of many settlements
and cities that cable discover across
the Galaxy and that includes the capital
of maragana a city on Tashara filled
with corruption and underworld activity
no okay Andy five is a BX Commando built
by the separatists and battle hardened
during the Clone Wars nowadays though he
serves as kind of an enforcer Droid in
the Underworld he's partnered with K as
they attempt to pull off a big high-risk
job it's the opportunity of a lifetime
not a friend
can't be trusted
who can out here
see you back at the ship
so various jobs and favors for the the
different characters and factions you
encounter they play an important role in
everything from learning new things
actually unlocking equipment and
abilities to managing your precious
reputation in the Underworld which is
the key to some of the most lucrative
opportunities out there important note
though something that's key to the
fantasy of the free scoundrel lifestyle
is that you're never in servitude of
anyone you're making your own choices
carving your own path through this world
making a name for yourself job was more
complicated than you said Danka
you lived
who she works for whether it's with
syndicates or otherwise is crucial to
creating a reputation for herself and
then how she approaches those syndicates
through those choices is going to be key
to getting bigger and better rewards
whether it's for credits or Priceless
artifacts
so nothing in the Underworld is black
and white and we wanted to reflect that
in the choices she makes when taking on
jobs this is one example of many does
she just hand over what was stolen keep
a cut for yourself lie about how the job
went down or the Intel she learned it's
really left up to her in these scenes
where we're going to give a choice to
the player and these choices there is no
wrong answer there's just ways to weave
Your Own Story ways to change challenge
increase your reputation with certain
factions and syndicates decrease it gain
an advantage or a different perspective
on the story too so we put a lot of
effort in giving the player agency over
their own trajectory
so the game takes place in the original
trilogy era so the Empire is at the
height of its power outage so they're
always looming there somewhere in the
background ever watchful but as you can
see here we want to show a different
side to the Empire and how it intersects
with the underworld and that means
corruption particularly on Tashara even
though it's Imperial run the local
Governors and officers lean into
corruption and I've worked out special
arrangements with the syndicates that
benefit them
so this is The Wanted system and The
Wanted system is something that's gonna
be ever present within the game if you
are quartz or challenge the Empire
you're gonna start to get wanted and if
you continue you persist and you do even
more actions that wanted levels just
gonna go up
at the highest levels the Empire will
throw a huge amount of resistance and
forces in your way so that's something
that you can play around with but you're
best of trying to avoid as much as
possible very important for us in this
experience is that there will always be
some way for you to de-escalate or
Escape
oh this is uh the Trailblazer now if
there's one dream that a lot of game
developers have it's the help design a
spaceship for Star Wars this is our take
on that the Trailblazer
Trailblazer is an EML 850 light
freighter from the Republic era but to K
this is home and if you're a scoundrel
traveling throughout the Galaxy the
first thing you need is a ship and 4K
there's none better than the Trailblazer
so now we're in space and you know one
of the things that was very precious to
us is having this seamless experience of
going on foot to your speeder to your
spaceship out of the atmosphere and into
space and space is a dangerous place but
it's a place full of opportunities too
so we'll be using it for combat both on
a an intimate dog fighting level an epic
level with bigger ships but also for
Discovery exploration and special
surprises
let's jump
[Music]
it's important to hit those classic
iconic notes of Star Wars so remind
players of the era that they're playing
in and the fact that the Galaxy is
something that is wide diverse but
iconic at the same time one of the
things that is important for us is that
every planet that you will visit in this
adventure has a distinct profile not
just a very bespoke story uh but also
Wildlife an ecosystem and situations
that really radically change from
location to location and space is just
another part of that so we're trying to
develop distinct profiles for every
single orbital region
yeah
we knew from the start when we sat down
thinking about this game that we wanted
to offer that full seamless experience
you know sitting in the Cantina in a
city on a planet surface jumping on your
own speed or driving to euron ship and
as we just saw seamlessly flying into
space is something that we're incredibly
pleased and happy and excited that we're
able to to actually offer
we really enjoyed making this and we
can't wait for you to experience a new
Star Wars Adventure
[Music]
we really want to bring an action
platformer and to respect from the
beginning the DNA of this brand of
course this new entry could be super
modern Super Fresh and I think this is
the Iranian of those two things our
expertise in platforming games and our
trunks there to be sure that this is a
true Prince of Persia game
combat system acrobatic puzzle narration
so we knew that because of our
experience on Rayman that we can bring
such kind of experience in 2D that's a
core experience is a principles again
Sargon is a brand new character in
Prince of Persia the Lost Crown is the
youngest of the Immortals The Immortals
are an elite Warrior team they fought
and won many metals together
let's go there we don't embody the
prince the prince is the one we have to
rescue that's one of the different
surprise that you will encounter in the
Lost Crown the monk CAF which is the
place where the adventures takes place
there's a curse time seems to be mixed
up doesn't follow anymore is natural
flow the story that one character will
leave will be different in terms of
timeline than the story of his friend so
sometimes the consequences and the
causes are mixed up
they left not long before us the
starting point Wells to immerse
ourselves in the Persian culture and
Legacy which is so rich when you learn
you have a strong emotion you are amazed
you want to translate that feeling to
the players a feeling of exploring
something new
and we get our inspiration from real
places like Paris or temper and even
some natural landscape like the Iranian
Forest which is a real Forest
it was really fresh to have a forest in
the franchise of Prince of Pasha I think
it will surprise the players and we have
also living elements like platforms that
ask you to shoot to activate it we think
that for Prince of Persia it's very
important to a domain platforming we
have level designers are very expert of
platforming because they worked on
Raymond and things like that and we also
try to have gameplayments that are
unique so like the Bears you have to
shoot to reveal platform when you create
this kind of game element we have a lot
of ideas so you understand that you
could do a navigation puzzle you could
do very tricky platforming and even you
could use it in combat if you have
enemies on it you just have to shoot the
bell and let the the enemy fall in those
Spike things like that I think the
strength of our game is that we have
characters it's really easy to handle so
we can easily
mix
Ed Edition I see a half and quarter and
wall everywhere
and that was something that we use a lot
for the platforming and combat you know
to a second personality is like
inventing his own movement so it was
really important to have the same
approach between the way he's moving
with the nice and smooth animation so of
course for the last Crown we are aiming
the highest animation quality as
possible
the way to animate without motion
capture you create everything actually
you you just take the puppets these are
if you ask for two actor to to grab one
by the head and launch it it's not just
possible so
cleverness and autonomy to be sure that
our players feel free to decide what is
the next subject
it's really important for us to make
sure that this game is modern and
respect players cleverness and autonomy
to be sure that our players feel free to
decide what is the next objective
because this is a genre where you are in
isolation this is a field that you have
in the first Prince of Persia
so it's very important to always give
information to players sometimes it's
obvious like a big gating in the big
landmarks sometimes it's been more
subtle it lets the player discover the
consistency of the world and or
everything is connected what we have
developed is a lot of things a new law
new characters a new combat system a new
art Direction a new narration so it's
something very important to say that
this team has made a wonderful job on
still working hard to bring the top
quality game
very important to talk about them
[Music]
hello I'm sharik Sarah I'm the art
director of Assassin's Creed Mirage hi
there I'm Stephen creative director of
an Assassin's Creed Mirage and today we
are going to work shoes through our most
recent trailer
welcome to Baghdad this is our first
glimpse of this vibrant City we are in
the 9th century Middle Ages and as you
can see it's a Dusty and sunny city as
expected but it's also a Garden City
with a lot of flowers and palm trees
so Basim is heading back to the bureau
in the way Istanbul on a specific Target
he has to kill so he will take this
opportunity to make the assassination
30 will quickly get into trouble
yeah and as we can see we can already
distinguish our first regular enemies
which are the California guard the guys
in red you're gonna meet a lot of them
it's a game we we encourage you to free
and to vanish is a glass Cannon
character and this scaffolding
ingredients in really one of the ways
players up to get a tight situation like
that
water City it's unexpected many people
think it's just dust and sand
we can see now Corner swings good old
vibes from previous AC games to the
first AC games we are a love letter to
the very first one
poop
ing
and here is a carpet as if you wish you
don't link you can see there is an
Assassin's Crest just your Capital are
part of the the world of uh of Mirage
this specific outfit with the Assassins
pressed on it means you are very very
close with secret entrance to a
necessant bureau
alhamdulillah
[Music]
is coming back from his first assignment
for killing a one of the main target of
the game
a first of many achievements to combust
him you we meet Abu Jafar this is one of
the historical characters we are going
to meet in Assassin's Creed Mirage is a
genius is a very important it's going to
provide you good tools there's still
much work to do
while our Focus was on our rule
full of quietly scouted the city for a
way we could elect more bureaus I have
found dwellings in three districts that
are most unassuming
I will make my way to sharkia shortly
and I will join Rebecca in Cara
where corruption is as common as the
Arid air
see Abu Jafar about some things he's
been working on then come find us
have a look Blossom I may have something
that is of interest to you
two are very important for an assassins
they will help you to deal with complex
situations
inside the game you will have the
possibility to unlock a new tool each
time you climb a rank by fulfilling your
assignments
[Music]
and each of your tools can be upgraded
as well through skill tree where you
will be able to choose the behavior of
your tools to match your play style for
instance you can decide to make the
projectile of your blood art damage your
enemies put them to sleep or turn them
berserk
the contract build is where are gathered
all the site faction assignments each of
them has a specific contractor request
also you might recall from a bus game
and you can try to fulfill them to gain
more Rewards
you can find materials for your tools
and your gear that you can find also a
specific token that will help you to
open new opportunities inside the
mission of the Sima
the lighting and Baghdad was the first
thing we set up with the artistic team
we wanted to have it right not to use
too much filters and other kind of
natural beauty of the lighting which is
really giving some gorgeous point of
views on the city itself at every time
of day so here you can have clips of
that what do you see in Hindu from a
personal perspective I grew up in this
place of the world and it was really the
first thing I want us to to be good at
was the lighting to give me the feeling
to be back here and I think we achieved
that
Assassin's Creed but first it was also a
necessary tool to bring back those
stealth moment to moment gameplay so you
will more rely on your Eagle Vision when
it's come to do infiltration look out
for guards or check their Vision cons
and Asus visioncons are new to
Assassin's Creedence
social stealth is back you can use it
organically
or you can bribe also Merchants group to
create a petrol branding opportunity to
infiltrate specific areas when we
crafted marriage we wanted to be able to
change tools quickly to face any
situation that's why we created this
wheel very reactive very immersive and
that will slow down time to let you
react
nothing
[Music]
yurizer Marksman above the tower and
it's uh why we cannot using kidu so we
will need to get rid of them
use the noisemaker to distract the first
guard the noise makers is very noisy and
can attract multiple NPCs in a given
Regis so by Simi air quickly reacts with
one of his skill letting him the
opportunity to use a knife to do a
double assassination and avoid
very efficiently to spread the alert I
know it's time to take down the pesky
Max one and to enjoy again the use of
Oracle and kidu and to enjoy Also the
view we are actually Advanced the prince
palace close to the Tigris River and uh
we are not just here to enjoy the
scenery but we have a Target to find
and here it is
assassin focus is a new ability for
besims that allows him to quickly chain
assassination
it's really a Showcase of passive
incredible agility and Mastery but of
course it's not something you can use
that will passing will need to perform
style skills to fill up his assassin
Focus gate to use this ability
oh yeah
here we can see passing planning is a
assassination but just before striking
it will land a trap
foreign
[Music]
that's uh my favorite too
and that's the end of our walkthrough we
hope you'll learn something new and we
cannot wait for you to play Assassin's
Creed Mirage when it comes out in
October 12th
foreign
[Music]